أن أنظمة التقاعد في كثير يتصور أنها فلوس تيجي من الحكومة
لا ترى الحكومة ما لها علاقة
الحكومة فقط تدير الصندوق هذا، وضامن في حال العجز
لكن الصندوق هو صندوق المواطنين ما بين متقاعدين، ومشتركين
المشترك يضع فيه فلوس، والمتقاعد يأخذ منه فلوس
كثير من الناس يتصور أن خلاص خلِّي الحكومة تتحمل العجز هذا
لو حصل خلل الحكومة راح تغطي العجز، ما في شك
لكن هذا راح يكون على حساب أمور أخرى
التغير الديموغرافي، والتغير في تركيبة السكان
أيش أثره؟
الآن اليوم نسبة كبار السن إلى القوَّة العاملة
اللي يسمونها نسبة التِّبعية 5.7%
5.7% تقريبًا متقاعدين، والباقي مشتركين
في عام 2070 النسبة هذه ستكون 40%
40% متقاعدين؟
40% متقاعدين
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
كل دولة عندها نظام للتأمينات الاجتماعية والتقاعد
السعودية تعمل بنظام تأمينات
يضمن للمشترك أنه يحصل على راتبه كامل
إذا أكمل المدة النظامية
راتبة كامل حتى يتوفى
ومو بس كذا، حتى بعدما يتوفى
هذا النظام كذلك هو الموجود في دول الخليج العربية
باختلافات طفيفة هنا وهناك
هل فيه مشكلة؟
ضيفي يقول فيه مشكلة، ولازم تتم إصلاحات
أو قد تكون عواقب تأخير هذه الإصلاحات بألم أشد
وين المشكلة طيب؟
المشكلة في أن السن التقاعدي قصير
مقابل زيادة واضحة في متوسط عمر الإنسان
والمشكلة الثانية هو نظام التقاعد المبكر
اللي يخلي الفجوة تكون أكبر مما يدفعه المشترك من الاستقطاع الشهري
وما يحصل عليه بعد التقاعد
تصل أنه يحصل على سبعة أضعاف من اللي دفعه، تخيل
واللي يدفع هذه الأضعاف كلها هو أنا، وأنت
المشكلة الثالثة: هي أن نسبة الخصوبة
أصبحت أقل مما كانت عليه في الجيل السابق
كانت تقريبًا سبعة أطفال لكل امرأة
والآن صار يا دوبك ثلاثة أطفال لكل امرأة
هذا يخل في التوازن التكافلي في نظام التأمينات
النتيجة أن العجز يزداد على كاهل التأمينات
وهذا العجز يستمر، ويتزايد بشكل قد يُهلك الميزانية العامة للدولة
وقد تكون الحلول حينها صعبة
طيب كيف نحل الموضوع بدون ما أحد يزعل؟
ضيفي عنده حلم ما يزعل المتقاعدين أبدًا
ضيفي الدكتور عمر المنيع
اقتصادي وشريك مؤسس في شركة «دينار للاستثمار»
وما أنسى الشكر لرعاة هذه الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
أولًا في الحلقة السابقة «حمد» في ثلاث حاجات
أول واحدة كتب تغريدة
أن طريقة الجلسة خلته أنه يبان أمتن
أتوقع أنك هذا أرفعه فوق ظهرك، خليه في ظهرك
يخلي جلستك أحسن
أنا ما عندي مشكلة
هذا أول واحد، أنه يطلع أحيانًا الواحد أمتن مما هو عليه
عاد أنا مجتهد الشهرين الماضية طيَّحت خمسة كيلو
ما ودِّي...
هذا واحد، اثنين أنه في موضوع تكلم فيه
بس حاولت أنه ما يستفيض فيه
وهو موضوع حلقتنا هذه كلها
سمعت أيش قال عليه؟
إي سمعت
في موضوع الضريبة اللي هو استفاض فيه، فودِّي أخذ رأيك
بس ليش إذا كل الاقتصادين يتَّفقون
أن ضريبة الدَّخل أحسن من ضريبة القيمة المضافة
فليش ما يطبق؟
أنا أقول خليها آخر الحلقة، أيش رأيك نبدأ في التقاعد وبعدين نرجع لها؟
أحسن، أبد اللي تبيه
أيش مشكلتك مع التقاعد؟
لا، بالعكس أشوف في التقاعد هو شيء...
أول شيء خليني أقول لك الصدق
أنا أتوقع أنك لا يمكن أنك تقنعني
أنا لاحظت في حلقة «حمد» واضح أنه...
أنه بواجه مشكلة
أنت ما تقدر تقنعني، أتوقع أني ما راح أقتنع
لكن قد نتفق على بعض الأشياء
ممتاز
حسنًا بس تتجهز ابدأ
لا، بس كويس أنك تأخذ الجانب الثاني
على أساس الموضوع يأخذ حقه شوي
لا، أنا بأخذه إنساني
وأنتم الاقتصاديين الإنسانية ما هي في معياركم
لا، لأننا إنسانيين الحين سنضمن الاستدامة المالية
على أساس الأجيال اللاحقة تأخذ، ونيجي لهذا الموضوع
أيش مشكلتك مع التقاعد؟
التقاعد أول شيء خلينا نفهم شلون أنظمة التقاعد تعمل
أنظمة التقاعد اليوم في نوعين: في النظام التكافلي خليني أسميه
اللي هو معاش تقاعدي محدد
هذا تسميه تكافلي؟
خلينا نسميه تكافلي عشان أسهل
ليش تكافلي؟
لأن المشتركين اليوم يدفعون للمتقاعدين اليوم
والفائض يُستثمر
المشتركين اليوم...
احنا اليوم نعمل مشتركين
فالفلوس اللي نودعها في التأمينات الاجتماعية
تأخذها التأمينات وتدفعها للمتقاعدين، والفائض يستثمر
هل في فائض؟
فيه فائض إي
هذا النظام الأول اللي هو معاش تقاعدي محدد
النظام الثاني اللي هو مساهمة محددة
اللي خلينا نسميه نظام الحصالة
ليه؟
لأنه هي فلوسك أنت لحالك
أنا أحط فيها فلوس، والشركة اللي أنا أعمل فيها أو الحكومة
تضع فيها فلوس ثم المبلغ هذا تديره مؤسسة مالية، ويستثمر
وإذا أنا تقاعدت، المبلغ هذا يجيني
أيش ما كان موجود في الحصالة، أيًا كان المبلغ
راح يجيني أنا في مرحلة التقاعة
ممتاز
هذا النظام المستقل أو نظام الحصالة والمساهمة المحددة
أيش الفرق، ليش الدول تفضل تروح للنظام التكافلي؟
معظم الدول نظام التكافلي
أنظمة التقاعد بدأت في الـ...
النظام الحديث خلينا نقول من الثلاثينيات والأربعينيات الميلادية
في معظم دول العالم
معظمها بدأت بالنظام التكافلي
لكن لمَّا واجه مشاكل أنه ما صار فيه استدامة مالية
بدأوا يحولون للنظام للمستقل
أيش إشكالية النظام المستقل؟
مشكلة النظام المستقل أن معاشات المتقاعد فيه أقل بكثير
من معاشات المتقاعد في النظام التكافلي
الفرق تتكلم عن 50%
بمعنى أنا لو أني متقاعد اليوم من النظام التكافلي
زي ما هو نظام التأمينات اليوم
ومعاشي التقاعدي تقريبًا 10 آلاف ريال
لو أروح نظام الحصالة ترى تقاعدي راح يصير 5 آلاف ريال
فرق الـ 50 هذه جاءت من وين؟
جاءت من العملية التكافلية، الناس تدفع لناس
طيب العملية التكافلية هذه كيف تتم؟
أو تراهن على أيش؟ تراهن على تركيبة السكان
لأن عندي أنا شباب كثير
وعندي متقاعدين قليل أو كبار السن قليل، فعندي فائض
أقدر هؤلاء يدفعون لهؤلاء مباشرة كجزء من المعاشات
ولا عندي مشكلة طالما أن كل الأجيال اللي بتيجي عُقب بنفس التركيبة
احنا اليوم جيلنا صحيح أن عددنا كبير جدًّا
نقعد ندفع اليوم على المتقاعدين قليلين
لكن احنا إذا تقاعدنا المفترض يجي جيل
بنفس النسبة، والتناسب عشان يدفع لنا
إذا ما جاء جيل بنفس النسبة والتناسب أيش يصير؟
تصير أزمة
تصير أزمة، طيب خلينا نيجي اليوم للأرقام
النظام التقاعدي تقريبًا صدر في الستينيات الميلادية
يمكن النظام الحالي صدر في عام 1973 ميلادي
ووقت صدور النظام...
وطبعًا لمَّا يرتبون أو يُهيكلون النظام
قبلما يحطوا أحكام النظام اللي هو الواحد يتقاعد بعمر كم؟
كم يصير معاشه، وكم يدفع اشتراكات المشترك وهكذا
يشوفون أيش طبيعة البلد ديموغرافيًّا
كم كبار سن، وكم متوقع يصير كبار سن مستقبلًا؟
ويوزنُوها بناءً عليها
وهذه يسمونها الدراسات الاكتوارية
وقت النظام لما عملوا الدراسات هذه
كان متوسط عمر الفرد آنذاك
تقريبًا ستة وخمسين سنة عام 1973
نتكلم عن السعودية؟
السعودية إي
الآن ارتفع إلى ستة وسبعين سنة، فعندنا زيادة عشرين سنة
أيضًا معدل الخصوبة
اللي هو المرأة كم يكون عندها أطفال هذه كانت 7.3
لكل امرأة؟
متوسط، لكل امرأة، اليوم 2.2 في السعودية
وإذا نشوفها بين السعوديات بس 2.8 فانخفاض ضخم جدًّا
طيب، الانخفاض هذا أيش يؤثر عليه؟
يؤثر عليه أنه إذا جاء مرحلة تقاعدنا
اليوم وضعنا كويس لأننا احنا كمشتركين
احنا السبعة فاصلة...
احنا الـ7.3 فإذا جاء وقتنا راح يجون الـ2.8
بيجي الجيل الجديد واحنا أصلًا بيصير نعيش أطول
فهنا المعادلة رياضيًّا ما تتبع
لأن هنا نقطة مهمة أن أنظمة التقاعد
في كثير يتصور أنها فلوس تيجي من الحكومة
لا ترى الحكومة ما لها علاقة
الحكومة فقط تدير الصندوق هذا، وضامن في حال العجز
لكن الصندوق هو صندوق المواطنين ما بين متقاعدين، ومشتركين
المشترك يضع فيه فلوس، والمتقاعد يأخذ منه فلوس
دور الحكومة أن حتى حسب النظام
لا بد كل ثلاثة سنوات يعملوا دراسة اكتوارية
حتى نشوف ملاءة هذا النظام، وأنه مستدام
لأن لو حصل فيه أي خلل بيصير في إشكالات كبيرة
طيب، التغير اللي قلناه قبل شوي اللي هو التغير الديموغرافي
والتغير في تركيبة السكان، أيش أثره؟
أو أيش الأرقام اليوم؟
اليوم، نسبة كبار السن إلى القوة العاملة
اللي يسموها نسبة الاعتماد 5.7%
5.7% تقريبًا متقاعدين والباقي مشتركين
في عام 2070
دائمًا الدراسات الاكتوارية تشوف خمسين سنة قدام
لأن أنا قاعد أشوف استدامة النسبة هذه بتكون 40%
40% متقاعدين؟
40% متقاعدين
طبعًا أربعين مو من 100، أربعين من 140
هي النسبة أربعين عندي متقاعدين
وبيكون عندي 100 المشتركين
لو نشوفها بطريقة ثانية
اليوم كل متقاعد أمامه عشرين مشترك يدفع له تقاعده
النسبة 5%
في وقت تقاعدنا بيكون تقريبًا النسبة هذه 2.5
يعني قدام كل متقاعد مشتركين 2.5
بدل ما هو قدامه عشرين
فالنظام التكافلي هنا ما راح يعمل بشكل كفؤ
مثلما كان يعمل...
كم يتطلب عشان يكون فيه نقطة تعادل
أو يكون مكان الاستدامة فيه موجودة
أن كم نسبة...
كم مشترك يدفع لكل متقاعد عشان يكون تمام؟
هي عملية التوازن
بمعنى أني أنا كم يتطلب، يعتمد على أنا أيش عندي من أحكام نظام؟
أنا اليوم كم سن التقاعد عندي؟
كم أدفع اشتراكات، وكم راتب المتقاعد؟
التقاعد المبكر وأحكامه وغيره
هذه لا بد أوزنها بطريقة
تتناسب مع اللي قاعد يصير في بيئة التركيبة السكانية
فهو كم يناسب؟ طبعًا الجواب الـ...
أرقام اليوم كمعاشات تناسب تركيبة سكان وقت النظام
وضحت؟
أحكام اليوم تناسب عشرين مشترك مقابل كل متقاعد
لكن بما أن هذا يتغير، فلا بد بأن يكون هناك تغيرات في أحكام النظام
الدول كثيرة
كيف الدول؟
موضوع التقاعد دائمًا موضوع حساس
وكثير من الدول ما تأخذ فيه إجراء بشكل خليني أقول استباقي بسبب حساسيته
مثلًا في هولندا في شهر مايو الماضي
وافقوا على تحويل نظام التقاعد من تكافلي إلى نظام الحصَّالة
كم قعد الموضوع في البرلمان؟
جلس أربعة عشر سنة، مداولات، ونقاشات لأن الموضوع...
والإشكالية أن هذا له تكلفة كلما تأخرت كلما صار الأثر أكبر بكثير
الدول اللي استطاعت أنها تغير بشكل استباقي
ما اضطرت أنها تحول من النظام التكافلي إلى نظام الحصالة
لأنها قدرت تغيّر أحكام التقاعد بشكل بسيط
مثلًا أرفع سن التقاعد من ستين إلى خمسة وستين
أرفع شوي الاشتراكات، أقلل شوي المعاشات
طبعًا نادر أن أحد يمسك أو يلمس المعاشات
لكن الفكرة أن الدول اللي استطاعت تواكب، وتغيِّر أنظمتها بشكل مستمر
هي اللي استطاعت تحافظ على الاستدامة
وللا اضطروا يحولون إلى نظام الحصالة
فأنت ممكن تكون مستدام بدون ما تحول حصالة؟
أي نعم ممكن تكون مستدام
فما تزال أغلب دول العالم اليوم على النظام التكافلي
أي في التكافلي ما يزال الغالبية
ولكن صار فيه تغيُّر جوهري من جانب آخر
لأن كثير من الدول بدأت تقلل النظام التكافلي
بالتوازي مع اللي قاعد يصير في الطبيعة الديموغرافية للبلد
ولكن أضافوا له النظام اللي هو التقاعد الاختياري
أو الاشتراكات الاختيارية اللي هو يسمى الركيزة الثالثة
هذا فكرته أن اليوم أي أحد متقاعد خلاص اشترك في الدولة بالنظام التكافلي
لكن ترى الاشتراك هذا يعطيك الحد الأدنى للمعيشة إذا جئت تتقاعد
يعطيك حد الكفاف
تبغى أكثر؟ تروح تشترك في النظام الاختياري
والنظام الاختياري يصير له حوافز إما الحكومة تدعمه
أو الحكومة تعطي عليه إعفاءات ضريبية
أو الحكومة تضمن حد أدنى من العائد
اللي يسمونه المساهمات المحددة الاسمية
فبعض الدول صار هذا هو خلينا نقول النظام الشائع
في أكثر الدول
وصار شوي يعوض، لو أخذنا أمريكا كمثال
في الضمان الاجتماعي هذا هو النظام التكافلي
بس إنه يعطيك الحد الأدنى
المتقاعد اللي يعمل أربعين سنة
أول راتب في التقاعد مقابل آخر راتب اللي يسمونه معدل الاستبدال
في أمريكا اليوم 39%
طبعًا عندنا في السعودية 100%
لو عملت كامل تأخذ راتب كامل
في أمريكا 39%
احنا في السعودية إذا كان راتبك 20 ألف
شوية بدالات والخرابيط بس أني أفرض أنه راتبك 20 ألف
تتقاعد وتأخد 20 ألف
إذا خدمت أربعين سنة
راتبك سيستمر إلى أن تموت وهو نفس الراتب
صحيح
في أمريكا إذا كان راتبك مثلًا 10 آلاف
بيصير 3900
ما شاء الله
لأن هدفهم هو أن هذا يعطيك الحد الادنى
لكن فيه الـ«401 كيه» اللي هو اختياري
لكن تقريبًا يطبق في معظم الشركات في أمريكا
لو الشركة ما طبقته يمكن ما أحد يشترك معها
ما أحد بيتوظف في الشركة هذه باستثناء بعض الشركات الصغيرة
هنا عليه حوافز ضريبة وغيره
في المتوسط في أمريكا اليوم
زي ما قلنا 3900 ريال تجي من النظام التكافلي
أو نظام التضامن الاجتماعي
4200 ريال تجي من الـ«401 كيه» النظام التقاعدي
فهذا اللي يصير أن الموظف
اختياري
الموظف يدفع، والشركة تدفع
والشركة تدفع
إي
تمام، تدري أيش ودِّي نسوِّي؟
بندخل على كل وحدة بس خلينا نمر عليها عشان لما نشرح التبادل
ولا نبغى نأخذ الأمثلة اللي تصير، والحلول
نكون شرحناها بالكامل
فعندنا التكافلية وشرحناها، باقي شيء بالتكافلية عشان يكون واضح؟
واضح
بعدين بنيجي للحصالة أو البرنامج المستقل، أيش شكله؟
شكله أن المشترك يدفع فلوس
والشركة اللي يعمل فيها تدفع كذلك اشتراك
والمبلغ هذا يودع بمؤسسة مالية، ويستثمر
طبعًا فيه خلينا نقول محافظ مختلفة
اختار المحفظة اللي تناسبك
ثم إذا تقاعدت يصرف من هذا المبلغ على تقاعدك
وفقًا لأداء محفظتك المالية
طيب لو خسرانة؟
لو خسرانة تتحمل الخسارة هذه
بعض الدول يسوون المساهمات المحددة الاسمية
هنا الدولة تضملك حد أدنى من العائد، تقول أضمن لك 5%
إذا كان أعلى كويس بس إذا قل عن 5% أنا أعوضك 5%
لكن هنا يصير نظام تبع الدولة، أو تديره الدولة استثماريًّا
الثاني...
ليش الدولة تضمن أداء القطاع الخاص؟
لأن الفكرة هي...
لا هي إذا كانت في حالة المساهمة المحددة
عادة يكون في إدارة الدولة
لكن الفكرة أن عادةً الدولة يهمها...
لأن نظام التقاعد هو ضمن إطار أنظمة الحماية الاجتماعية
الدولة يهمها أن المتقاعد يكون في مستوى رفاهية معين
مستوى جودة حياة معينة
حتى اليوم مثلًا لما قلنا أنه ارتفاع السن
كل هذا صار بسبب أن، الحمد لله
الصرف اللي كان على الرعاية الصحية وجودة الحياة
كلها عُكست يعني زادت الأعمار عشرين سنة
الدولة يهمها رفاهية المواطن
فما تبغى أحد في وقت التقاعد ينزل عن مثلًا مستوى..
يكون على الحد الأدنى، فلذلك يضمن له الحد الأدنى من العائد
افترض أنه بعد عشرين سنة من تقاعدة حصالته انتهت
الدولة تبدأ تدخله في أنظمة الحماية الاجتماعية الثانية
هذه الحصالة، اللي الآن يصير مثلًا في السعودية اللي هو التكافلي
هو بالإجبار أنت ما عندك خيار
أنت 18% بتأخذها التأمينات
على طول ما تتكلم فيها هي مخصومة من راتبك
ولا عندك خيار أنك تقول لا والله تصدقون أنا ما ودِّي
إي ما فيه
إي ما فيه التأمينات بيأخذونها غصب
صح
في الحصالة، هل هو إلزامي في الدول اللي تطبق هذا
ودِّي أعرف أصلًا أيش الدول اللي تطبقها
بس هل هو إلزامي أنك يجب تحط هذا الكم من الفلوس
بس وين تحطه ما أدري
بس لازم هذه الفلوس تطلع وللا لا؟ ولا هو اختياري؟
في دول ما عندها زي النرويج وإيطاليا والسويد والتشيلي
هذه الدول ما عندها أصلًا النظام التكافلي
فتروح إلى نظام المستقل، ويكون إجباري
في حد أدنى من الاشتراك لازم تدفعه
أنت لازم تدفع الشركة اللي تعمل فيها
إذا كانت الدولة عندها النموذجين
عندها التكافلي لكنه يعطي الحد الأدنى
فهي تروح تعطي حوافز على الاختياري
هو يصير اختياري، ولكن تعطي عليه حوافز
ولكن هذا...
يعني الإعفاءات الضريبية
أحيانًا الدولة تضمن عائد معين فيه
أو أنها أحيانًا تدفع حتى جزء من الاشتراكات
وهذا مع الوقت ينتشر، ويصير أصلًا كل...
كل الناس تسويه
كل الناس تسويه حتى لو أنه اختياري
مثلما يصير في أمريكا ال«401 كيه» جدًّا شائع
فهذا بالنسبة للـ...
طيب، الحين عندنا هذه الثلاثة أنظمة
احنا في السعودية نستخدم هذا
كثير، أتذكر في لقاء قديم
قد طلع أحد وتكلم أنه يعني كثير فيه اللي ينتقدونه
وأتذكر يمكن هذا اللي، ناسي أيش كان منصبه
بس أنه كان في التأمينات الاجتماعية
وتكلم عن أنه الصندوق الظاهر أنه خسران أو شيء زي كذا
بس الناس ما تحب أن أحد يتكلم على التأمينات الاجتماعية كناس
والاقتصاديين عندهم مشكلة، فأيش مشكلتك معه؟
الحين نتكلم عن التأمينات الاجتماعية في السعودية
ممتاز
أو أتوقع أن في السعودية وفي الخليج كله نفس الشيء؟
مقارب إي كلها مقاربة
كلها تكافلية وكلها...
من ناحية أنها كلها تكافلية، وحتى نسب اقتطاع متقاربة وأحكام متقاربة
وكلها تعطي 100%؟
لا، يختلف
في أحد يعطي أقل من...؟
إي، فيه تباين أقل وأكثر حتى
المعادلة التقاعدية، ما تقدر تناظرها ...
ما تقدر تأخذ مؤشر واحد وتقيس فيه
لأنك لازم تشوف كل المؤشرات، زين
لازم تشوف كم الاشتراك، وكم المعاش، وكيف حساب المعاش
إذا يأخذ آخر راتب غير يأخذ متوسط راتب آخر سنتين
بعضهم يأخذ كل سنوات الخدمة
وإذا أخذ كل سنوات الخدمة، في شيء يسمونه التسوية
أو أنه يحسب الراتب بناءً على التضخم
يعني راتب قبل عشرين سنة كان 7 آلاف
ما يحسبه 7 آلاف يسجله 12 ألف لأنه يشوف القوة الشرائية له
ففي أنظمة التقاعد
شبه مستحيل أنك تأخذ مؤشر واحد، وتقيس عليه في الدول الثانية
لكن أنظمة الخليج بما أني ذكرتها
وراح نيجي على نظام التأمينات الاجتماعية
عندنا في سعودية في نظام الخليج عندنا
طبعًا كل أنظمة الخليج تعاني نفس الأشكالية
ومستوى الاستدامة المالية فيها ضعيف جدًّا
يمكن الاستثناء طبعًا قطر نظام التقاعد
أو التأمينات الاجتماعية عندهم خلينا نقول
طبعًا ما فيه استدامة مالية يعني جدًّا غير قابل للاستدامة
ولكن عدد المتقاعدين القليل يساعد وجود أحكام شوي خلينا نقول غير منطقية
مثلًا، اليوم عدد المتقاعدين في قطر 18 ألف متقاعد
في السعودية عندنا أكثر من مليون متقاعد
هذا اليوم والنمو قاعد ينمو بشكل كبير
خلينا نقول هذه تعطي مساحة شوي
حتى لو صارت مشكلة ترى المشكلة
على 18 ألف واحد
قياسًا بالأثر على المالية العامة والاستدامة المالية ما هو بالكثير
باقي دول الخليج عندها نفس الإشكالية وعملت على إصلاحات
يعني أبوظبي غيرت في السنة هذه عدد من الإصلاحات يعني سن التقاعد المبكر
رفعوه من خمسة وأربعين سنة إلى خمسة وخمسين سنة
طبعًا بشكل تدريجي
نفس الشيء عُمان أصدرت نظام جديد في السنة هذه
في سبيل هذا الإصلاح، وأن يكون فيه استدامة مالية
عُمان يمكن عندها أكثر من ثمانية أنظمة تقاعدية ودمجت
وبالتالي صار...
وصدرت أحكام جديدة، ورفعوا سن التقاعد من ستين إلى خمسة وستين
ولكن بشكل تدريجي
هذا بالنسبة للخليج فكلنا عندنا نفس الإشكال
وكل الدول عندها نفس التوجه
من ناحية أنها تبحث عن إصلاح واستدامة أنظمتها
بالنسبة للتأمينات
احنا أول شيء فهمنا المشكلة والنظام التكافلي كيف يعمل
كيف جاء التأثير عليه من ناحية تركيبة السكان
أيش وضح مثلًا اليوم التنميات الاجتماعية؟
التنميات الاجتماعية اليوم مثلًا الصندوق حجمه تقريبًا أكثر من 300 مليار دولار
هذا شيء أنا أقوله لأن ترى الوضع ليس بالسوء اللي نتكلم عنه
لما أقول مثلًا عشرين متقاعد
أو عشرين مشترك يدفع لمتقاعد وبيصيرون اثنين
الموضوع هذا سيء أكيد
لكن ما يزال عندنا مساحة كافية للتعديل والإصلاحات
بدون ما يكون في أثر كبير يمس المشترك أو المتقاعد
مثلًا، اليوم صندوق التأمينات اللي هو ذراع استثماري لها
اللي هي شركة حصانة أصولها أكثر من 300 مليار دولار
هذا يخليها من أكبر عشر صناديق تقاعد في العالم
حتى نأخذها في السياق أو حتى تسهل المقارنة
الصندوق أكبر من أكبر عشر صناديق تقاعد في أفريقيا مجتمعة
فالحمد لله، في أصول ممتازة كُونت أو تكونت خلال سنوات، وعقود
هذا الشيء يُعطي مساحة جيدة
لكن في تغيرات في الديموغرافيا
اللي بيصير أن لا بد يكون في إصلاحات تتعلق بتغيير بعض الأحكام، وتعديلها
وهذا يمكن نيجي لها بعد شوي، ونفصل فيها أكثر
لأنه إذا ما تم هذا الشيء
مع الوقت راح نضطر أننا نحول إلى نظام الحصالة
وإذا حولنا إلى نظام الحصالة، وهذا ما هو شيء جديد ترى دول كثير
ما في أحد من الدول يحول لنظام الحصالة برغبته وإرادته
فرض عليه الوضع
فاحنا نأمل أنه يكون في تغييرات قبل أن نضطر إلى التغيير اللي...
أن نكون أمام الواقع، ونغير تغيرات سيئة
مثلًا اليوم في البرازيل صار في إصلاحات كبيرة الفترة اللي راحت
تخيل اليوم أن العجز المالي
طبعًا البرازيل من الدول اللي تأخرت في الإصلاح
اليوم حجم العجز لما نقول أن الحكومة ضامن لعجز الصندوق
كثير من الناس يتصور أن خلص خلوا الحكومة تتحمل العجز هذا
الكلام هذا منطقي لكن في النهاية قلنا الصندوق للمواطنين
الحكومة تتولى الإدارة عليه وإشراف على إدارته واستدامته
لو حصل خلل الحكومة راح تغطي العجز ما في شك
لكن هذا سيكون على حساب أمور أخرى
سيكون على حساب الميزانية العامة
وبالتالي هذا بالنهاية بيرجع ضرره على المواطن بشكل غير مباشر
شوف اليوم في البرازيل مثلًا
عجز التقاعد اللي يُغطى من خلال الحكومة من خلال الميزانية العامة
يشكل تقريبًا 16% من إجمالي إنفاق الميزانية
عشان نضعه في سياق يفهمه المستمع اليوم لو نشوف
بند الصحة في الميزانية العامة في السعودية يشكل 17%
تقريبًا احنا اليوم في كل دول العالم
عندنا ثلاثة بنود رئيسية الصحة والتعليم والدفاع
ما نبغى بعدين يصير معانا التقاعد
عرفت شلون؟
لأن هذا بيكون على حساب البنود الأخرى
بيصير على حساب أن الدولة تبدأ تبحث عن مصادر تمويل أخرى
مثل ضريبة القيمة المضافة أو ضريبة الدخل
أو أنها بتأخذ من الدفاع أو الصحة أو التعليم
بالضبط
عشان تعطي الـ..
100% فهذا الشيء هو المرحلة اللي الاقتصاديين
لما تقول أنه عندهم مشكلة مع التقاعد
الاقتصاديين هذا الكلام اللي هم يبون يوصلونه
أن نبدأ بإصلاحات اليوم أثرها ما راح يكون كبير
لكن في المقابل تجنبنا تبعات كبيرة لو تأخرنا في عملية الإصلاح
بس احنا بنتفق برضو أن التأمينات الاجتماعية
مو مكان ربحي، والصندوق ليس هدفه الربح
هو مكان للي أنت ذكرته في البداية اللي هي الحماية المجتمعية
وإذا كان في تقصير وغيره أنه جزء من دور الحكومة
والحكومة ما يمدك...
هي شغلتين جزء من دور الحكومة أنها بتدعمه
ولا يمدك أن تسحب أن الحكومة ما لها علاقة
صح
الحكومة صحيح أن ما لها علاقة في كيف...
صحيح الفلوس تيجي من المواطنين إلى المواطنين
بس هي من يديره
طبعًا
فإذا خسر هو...
يعني قدرته على أن الصندوق يقولون خسران أو ربحان عندها
فهي الاستثمارات هو اللي يقودها صح؟
صح
من خلال شركة مثلًا هنا «حَصان» أو غيره
وفي كل الدول نفس الشيء أتوقع
اثنين: أن الحكومة هي من يشرّع التشريعات
اللي تساهم بشكل أو آخر في شكل أداء الصندوق أو غيره
من خلال التقاعد، يعني ما أحد يقدر يسويها إلَّا الحكومة
الحكومة جزء مهم من أداءها، فإذا صار...
فالمفترض أنه مو مكان ربحي، عادي لو يكون مكان عجز
لأن الحكومة لما تدفع للصحة
ما هو عشان نشوف كم العائد الاستثماري على الصحة
هو لأنه في الأخير الهدف هو على حسب أيش مستهدفات الحكومة
الرفاه الاجتماعي والصحة الجيدة وأمان مالي
لكن الصندوق لا هدفه ربحي
لأنه ربحي حتى يستطيع يدفع للمشتركين تقاعداتهم المستقبلية
فلا هدفه طبعًا لربحي من منظور الشركة
وزي منظورنا كمشتركين متقاعدين
احنا نطمح أن الصندوقي يحقق أعلى عائد ممكن
لأن هذا بيأثر بشكل كبير على مستويات معاشاتنا مستقبلًا
لكن زي ما تفضلت في تداخل هنا في هذه الأمور
هل الصندوق هذا اليوم يفكر خلاص أنه يصير ربحي 100%؟
هذا لا يمكن يصير، ليش؟ لأنه طبعًا...
أو خلّينى أقولها لا يمكن أنا كحكومة أسمح بهذا الشيء يصير
لأنه لو صار هذا الشيء معناه أنه جزء كبير من استثمارات الصندوق هذا
موجود اليوم في داخل السعودية
لو بيصير يركز فقط على الربحية معناته يحتاج مقياس أكبر للاستثمار
معناته لازم يطلع برة السعودية
وعادةً أصلًا كأنظمة تقاعد أنت لما يصير استثمارك في السعودية
وأنت بتدفع اشتراكاتك في السعودية، وعواملك تتأثر في السعودية
يصير أفضل لك من باب توزيع المخاطر على الصندوق
أنك تستثمر برة السعودية
بس هل الشيء يصير من منظور حكومي، هل هذا أفضل؟
قطعًا لا، ليش؟
لأن الصندوق اليوم لو بيطلع برة السعودية
معناه بيسحب دولارات كبيرة
من الاحتياطي الموجودة بالبنك المركزي
معناته أنه بيصير استثمارات كبيرة في سوق الأسهم
وأحد أكبر ملَّاك سوق الأسهم
وهذا يؤثر على أسواق الأسهم
ومعناه أنه حتى على النظام المالي
جزء كبير من الودائع الموجودة في القطاع المالي
بشكل مباشر أو غير مباشر جاية من هذا المستثمر الضخم
اللي هو من أكبر عشر صناديق تقاعد في العالم
احنا اننا نفكر فيه، في المعادلة هذه شوي حساسة، وصعبة
والأمر الثاني أنه حتى لما نشوف مثلًا في التسعينيات
من منتصف الثمانينيات تقريبًا
من انخفض أسعار النفط في عام 1986 إلى نهاية التسعينيات
في تلك الفترة كان في عجز مالي في الحكومة
كانت تشترى سندات التنمية الحكومية
أكثر من كان يشتريها في تلك الفترة على حد علمي
التقاعد والتأمينات كنوع من...
هو مستثمر مسؤول في النهاية
لأن في تلك الفترة 50% من أصول البنوك السعودية طلعت برة السعودية
كان يمكن ذروتها صارت عام 1991
في عام 1991، 52% من أصول البنوك طلعت برة السعودية
بمعنى أن البنوك تأخذ ودائع محلية
وتستثمر بها في أصول أو تقرضها في أصول برة السعودية
وهذا كان له أثر تنموي كبير
البنوك تسويها لأن تفكيرها استثماري صِرف
لكن أنا كتقاعد، وتأمينات لا يمكن أن هذا الشيء يتم
الأمر الثاني اللي هو موضوع الـ...
العائد الاستثماري لا شك أنه مهم جدًّا في حجم التقاعد، والمعاشات
ولكن زي ما قلت لك ومهما حققت من عائد
أثر التغيرات الديموغرافية يغطي على أي عائد ممكن تجيبه
هذه النقطة الأولى
النقطة الثانية: أن كثير يتصورون أن عوائد التقاعد، ولا التأمينات
المفترض تصير 10% أو 12%
هذا على مستوى المستثمر الفرد
أو المؤسسات المالية الصغيرة أو الشركات الصغيرة
لكن مستوى صناديق التقاعد ما تصل هذه الأرقام
أفضل صندوق تقاعد أداءً هو الصندوق السيادي النرويجي
الصندوق التقاعد النرويجي
حقق متوسط خمسة عشر سنة 5.7%
لأنه يشتغل على مخاطر أقل، وللا أيش السبب؟
إي لأن «وارن بافت» يقول: أكبر عدو لتحقيق العائد هو المحفظة الضخمة
لأنه حتى «وارن بافت» عوائده في بداياته كانت عالية
لكن لما كبرت محفظته بدأت تُخفض عوائدها
لأن العوائد العالية تصير مقياس عالي
اليوم كلما كبرت المحفظة
يصير الرابط أو اللي يحدد أداءك بشكل كبير
هو أسعار الفائدة السائدة في السوق
هذا هو الأساس اللي أنت قاعد تبني عليه
ولا تقدر تروح اليوم
ما راح تقدر تشتغل بترليون و300 مليار
مثلما ما تشتغل بـ10 مليون، ما راح تقدر
كم العائد اللي يحققه الصندوق السيادي النرويجي؟
ناسي الرقم بس أتوقع
5.7%
هو نفسه ولا في صندوقين مختلفين؟
لا هو على حد علمي، أنه صندوق التقاعد النرويجي
هو يأخذ من التقاعدات
شوف النرويج وضعها شوي شائك لأنه في عندهم نظام الحصالة
هذا مستقل ما نتكلم عنه
وفيه النظام اللي يعطيك الحد الأدنى
اللي مصادره من اشتراكات المواطنين ومن ريع النفط
وحقق تقريبًا 5.7% خلال خمسة عشر سنة الماضية
طبعًا فيه دول، في تقرير اسمه «المعاش التقاعدي في لمحة»
ممكن نحطه في وصف الحلقة
يصير فيه كل تفاصيل كل صناديق التقاعد
في دول مثلًا كولومبيا وتركيا حققت 9-10%
لكن بسبب انهيار عملاتها
فهذا الشيء ما ودِّك يصير
لأنه جاء ببالي احنا عندنا صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
اللي هو الصندوق السيادي الأكبر للدولة
منفصل عن صندوق التأمينات الاجتماعية
إي ما له علاقة
فظننت أنه في النرويج أن هذا الانفصال
وأعتقد أن عائد الصندوق الاستثمارات العامة أعلى من 5%
إي الهدف مختلف
قصدي أن إذا كبر برضو يمديك تجيب عائد
بس قلت يمكن المخاطرة هنا أقل أو ما أعرف
بالحجم الكبير هذا ما أتصور، ولكن بصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
عمومًا هدفه مختلف، يعني هدفه تنموي، ومشاريع تنموية
يمكن فيه استثمارات معينة دخل فيها أداء ممتاز جدًّا
لكن لما تشوف المحفظة بشكل إجمالي
صعب أنها تحقق عوائد عالية
والهدف منه هو هدف تنموي
التصور من المشاريع اللي احنا نشوفها اليوم
مشاريع الـ«قيقا» وغيره
الهدف خلق نمو اقتصادي
أكثر من أنه تحقيق عائد على الاستثمار
ممتاز نرجع إلى التأمينات الاجتماعية
طيب إذا هو جالس يحقق عوائد جيدة ورقم هائل
ليش في عجز؟
طبعًا للتوضيح، ما في إفصاح عن كم يحقق عائد التنمية الاجتماعية
كم العائد؟ ما أعرف شخصيًّا
بس الظاهر رئيس «حصانة»
قال أن أرباحها 14% زيادة عن السنة الماضية
في إفصاحات في سنوات محددة
لكن هذا لا يعطينا صورة عامة عن كيف الأداء
أحتاج أعرف صندوق الأداء لثلاثين سنة أو أقل شيء خمسة عشر سنة
لأني قاعد أشوف الاستدامة المالية على مدى البعيد
من ضمن الإفصاحات، كان في الإفصاح اللي تفضلت فيه
كان برضو في إفصاح محافظ التأمينات أتوقع «سليمان القويز»
كان في 2017 أو 2018
أنه العائد كان موازي لمتوسط أداء دول منظمة التعاون الاقتصادي والتنمية
على متوسط خمس سنوات
أيش هي دول منظمة التعاون الاقتصادي والتنمية؟
اللي هي دول منظمة التعاون والتنمية
مجموعة من الدول المتقدمة
دول أوربا وأمريكا الشمالية حققت تقريبًا في وقت التصريح أتذكر
كانوا محققين الدول هذه المتوسط أعتقد 5 أو 6%
اللي أقصده، طبعًا هذه التأمينات، طيب أيش وضع التقاعد؟
أيضًا، هذا في فترة معينة نحتاج فترة أطول
احنا ما ندري كم الأداء
ممكن أن يكون أفضل مما هو متوقع
ممكن أن يكون أقل
لكن المقصد بغض النظر عن الأداء
حتى لو كان الأداء 20% أو 15%
ما راح يغير شيء من الصورة لأن التغير الديموغرافي
ما راح يغير شيء من الصورة بشكل جوهري
لأن التغير الديمغرافي هو المحدد الأكبر
لأن الصندوق تكافلي هو ما يعتمد على العائد بشكل أساسي
نصف الاشتراك اللي يجيك
ما يجي من خلال اشتراكك إنما يجي من خلال العملية التكافلية
طيب خلنا نروح للحلول، اعطيني حلول
اللي نبغى نحلها لأن يكون...
قبل بس فيه تعريج بسيط
احنا قلنا فيه تحديين أمام الصندوق
التحدي الأول، اللي هو تحدي العجز
بسبب التغير الديمغرافي بشكل رئيسي
في تحدي ثاني اللي هو ضعف العدالة
ضعف العدالة في النظام
من جوانب مختلفة، أول شيء مثلًا
التقاعد المبكر، والتقاعد النظامي على سبيل المثال
اليوم الواحد لو اشترك
أنا أخذت مثال شخص توظف براتب 5 آلاف ريال
أعمل ثمانية وثلاثين سنة ثم تقاعد
وقتها التقاعد أعتقد كان 20 ألف
فمثال أعتقد ينطبق على كثير من الناس
في المتقاعد هذا اللي خدم كامل الخدمة تقاعد بعمر ستين
وبالمناسبة ستين هجري، يعني فعليًّا ثمانية وخمسين ميلادي
لو تقاعد بعمر الستين
ثم عاش إلى ستة وستين سنة وهو متوسط الأعمار
ترى ستة وسبعين هذا متوسط الأعمار منذ الولادة
متوسط الأعمار للمتقاعدين أعلى
فإذا وصل هو لسن الستة وسبعين
يأخذ في العادة عنده تقريبًا أربعة أضعاف المبالغ اللي اشتركها
يعني نجمع مجموع اشتراكاته والمجموع اللي أخذه
هو أخذ أربعة أضعاف
أربعة أضعاف اللي هو دفعه من استقطاعاته
استقطاعاته واستقطاعات الشركة
هذا بالنسبة للمتقاعد النظامي وخدم كامل الخدمة
المتقاعد المبكر نفس المثال
لكن نفترض أنه تقاعد بعدما خدم عشرين سنة
فهذا أخذ سبعة أضعاف المبلغ اللي يدفعه
التقاعد المبكر خمسة وأربعين؟
التقاعد المبكر مربوط بعشرين سنة في التقاعد المدني
بموافقة رئيس الجهة
وفي التأمينات الاجتماعية خمسة وعشرين سنة
وفي النظام العسكري أعتقد ينزل إلى خمسة عشر سنة حسب الرتبة
لكن الفكرة أنه هذا أخذ أربعة أضعاف
اللي اجتهد وكمل كامل الخدمة، واللي عادةً يكون أكثر حاجة
اللي يتقاعد تقاعد مبكر بيقل راتبه بشكل أكبر
فمو منطقي أنه يتقاعد مبكر إلا أنه عنده دخل ثاني
أو أنه مثلًا يروح يعمل عمل إضافي، وهذا الغالب
سواءً عمل خاص، هو فعليًّا ما تقاعد
لكنه استغل الثغرة الموجودة في أحكام النظام
وبالتالي السبعة أضعاف هذه أخذها من وين؟
من التكافل، أخذها من التقاعد النظامي
فعدم وجود العدالة هذا شوي مؤثر
كم يأخذ من نسبة راتبه اللي يتقاعد تقاعد مبكر؟
50%
50% من راتبه ينزل؟
إي 50%
طبعًا على حسب كم الخدمة هي تبدأ من خمسين
وعاد توصل إلى أن تكمل النظام اللي هو 100%
النقطة الثانية اللي هو موضوع بعض الثغرات
في التأمينات الاجتماعية فيما يتعلق بالراتب
احنا الراتب أو معاش تقاعدي يحسب على متوسط آخر سنتين
عندنا سنتين؟
آخر سنتين إي
فهم عادةً تلقاه مسجل برواتب منخفضة
وهذا نشوفه اليوم ممارسة شائعة صار في الشركات
يسجلون برواتب منخفضة
على أساس يخفضون الاشتراك اللي بيدفعه هو، واللي بتدفعه الجهة
لكن إذا وصل حول السنتين سيبدأ يرفع راتبه
على أساس أنه يبدأ يعوض النقطة هذه
طبعًا صار فيه تعديلات عليه
أنه صار فيه سقف أعتقد 10% لآخر خمسة أو عشرة سنوات
لكن بصورة عامة يصير فيه تلاعب في هذا الجانب
فاللي يستخدم هذه الثغرة يحصل عوائد عالية جدًّا مقارنة بغيره
ويهلك الصندوق
ويهلك الصندوق على حساب الباقيين طبعًا
نفس الشيء الـ...
طبعًا هذا بالمناسبة صندوق التقاعد المدني أول ما طلع
كان بنفس السيناريو كان ما تأخذ آخر راتب
كان يحسب متوسط آخر سنتين
لكن بعدما صدر نظام سنتين صدر مرسوم ملكي بتحديث الفقرة هذه
وصار يعتمد على آخر راتب
لكن النظام المدني ما فيه إشكال بحكم أنه صلًا
سلم حكومي ما أحد يقدر يتلاعب فيه
الحين هو أصبح، والتنمية الاجتماعية واحد ولا؟
لا، دُمجت الأنظمة الإدارية لكن أنظمة التقاعد ما زالت مفصولة
النقطة الثانية من ضمن عدم العدالة هي موضوع السَّعودة الوهمية
التوطين الوهمي
ما أحد يعرف كم الأرقام لكن مئات آلاف أكيد من الموظفين سعودة
هذول يشتركوا في مبالغ صغيرة جدًّا
هو أصلًا ما هو مشترك حقيقي، لكن فقط يسجل اسمه بوزارة العمل
ووزارة المورد البشرية وغيره
وفي النهاية راح يتقاعد، وراح تحسب له هذه الخدمات
ما هي بمنطقية أو ما هي بواقعية
فوجود الثغرات هذه
هي في النهاية زي ما قلت لك الصندوق من الجميع وإلى الجميع
فإذا راح من فئة بيأثر على فئة
لأني شفت تغريدة قبل كم يوم
لأحد فكان يقول أنه أفضل شيء تسويه لابنك
أنك تدخله التأمينات الاجتماعية
واقتبس تغريدة برضو للتأمينات الاجتماعية
فهي ثغرة، هو ما يسوي شيء غلط
بس إنها غلط
صح، أخلاقيًّا
إي فهو أن أفضل شيء تسويه لابنك
أنك تدخله التأمينات الاجتماعية من عمره خمسة عشر سنة
صح
فأيش اللي يسوونه؟
أحس أنك يمديك تحطه بأي مؤسسة
فأنت تسوي مؤسسة تدفع 500 ريال رسوم سجل تجاري
تحط أولادك عليهم وتجي تدفع رسوم بسيطة
ويحسب له يمكن سبعة سنين وهو ما اشتغل
صح
الحين تقريبًا سبعة أو عشرة سنين من حياته لسه
ما بين متوسط، وثانوي، وجامعة، خلص عشرة سنين
الحين باقي له ثلاثين سنة ويتقاعد
صحيح
تقاعد...
نظامي
صحيح، وجود هذه الثغرات إشكالية كبيرة
أيضًا أكبر إشكالية اللي هو عدم وجود العدالة بين الأجيال
أيش تقصد؟
اليوم الجيل إذا استمرت هذه العجوزات بهذه الصورة
وما تم إصلاح واستدامة مالية
فهذا على حساب جيلنا
جيلنا اللي احنا اليوم موجودين في الاستوديو
احنا راح ندفع الثمن هذا، وضحت؟
الجيل اللي بعدنا راح يدفع الثمن مضاعف
ممتاز؟
طبعًا إذا ما حصل إصلاحات في الاستدامة
فدائمًا عند تصميم النظام وأحكامه
لا بد أن يكون بالاعتبار وجود عدالة بين الأجيال
العدالة بكل بساطة أن يكون في استدامة مالية
بحيث نضمن أنه احنا إذا تقاعدنا بيصير لنا تقاعد
عيالنا إذا تقاعدوا بيصير عندهم تقاعد
وبمستوى مجزي ما يكون حد الكفاف، فهذا الشيء مهم جدًّا
طيب نجي للموضوع اللي تفضلت فيه موضوع الإصلاحات
أيش ممكن يصير؟
طبعًا فيه زي ما قلنا بعض الدول اللي تأخرت عاد تحولت للحصالة
إن شاء الله، احنا بعيدين أتصور كل البعد عن هذا الشيء
للإيضاح أنا مالي أي صلة في موضوع التقاعد إطلاقًا
الأمر الثاني، أن ليس عندي كل المعلومات
لأن الكثير من المعلومات أصلًا غير منشورة
فهي فقط أمور تقديرية
لكن نحاول أحيانًا نستفيد
أنا أكثر شيء يعطيني معلومات
لما يُعرض التقرير السنوي للتنميات الاجتماعية في مجلس الشورى
لأن يصير فيه تعليقات من أعضاء المجلس على النظام
ويصير فيه اصلًا صحفيين موجودين فيسجلون
فهذا أكثر شيء تلقى فيه معلومات
آخر جلسة أعتقد كانت السنة هذه
من ضمن الإفصاحات المهمة
أهم إفصاح اللي هو موضوع العجز الاكتواري
كم العجز الاكتواري اليوم الموجود عندنا
نتكلم عن عجز ومتقاعدين عددهم بيصير كبير مستقبلًا
طيب العجز هذا كم قيمته؟
لأنه يفرق في السياق، أنا لما أتكلم عن عجز 50 مليار
خلاص خلِّي الحكومة تحمل عادي، مافي إشكال
فرقم العجز أعتقد أنه مرَّة مهم
ولا أُعلن رسميًّا ولا منشور
لكن ناقشه أحد أعضاء مجلس الشورى في الجلسة الماضية
وذكر أن العجز 800 مليار ريال
طبعًا هذا العجز 800 مليار ريال
أيش نقصد بالعجز الاكتواري؟
معناه الحكومة حتى تحل الإشكال هذا لازم تضخ اليوم 800 مليار
وللعجز الاكتواري على المدى البعيد أكثر من 800 مليار
لكن حتى أحله أحط اليوم 800 وأستثمرها عشان أحل النظام
بحسب التصريح الموجود
وهذا رقم منطقي إذا ما كان حتى متحفظ
أنت كنت متوقع أنه في هذه الحدود ولا تفاجأت؟
لا، أنا تفاجأت شوي، ارتحت
كان التصور والله عندي أكبر من الرقم
بالنظر إلى الوضع الديموغرافي والتغير الكبير
شوف الرقم يتغير من 800 مليار إلى 2 تريليون مثلًا
بناءً على افترىض بسيط أغيره
اللي هو مثلًا افتراض معدل الخصوبة ترى هذا يغير كل المعادلة
يمكن يرتفع 800 مليار إلى 2 تريليون
وتنخفض إلى 300، فهو حساس جدًّا للافتراضات
لكن طبعًا ما هو برقم مخيف
طبعًا هو إذا أحد شافه يقول رقم مخيف
لكن الرقم هذا ممكن كله يروح بتعديلات بسيطة على النظام
وهذا الشيء الجيد في أنظمة التقاعد
أيش التعديلات اللي...؟
التعديلات مثلًا خلينا نأخذ مثلًا أمثلة...
طبعًا دول أشهر شيء تغيره الدول هو رفع سن التقاعد
اليوم مثلًا سن التقاعد وصل في بعض الدول اللي احتدت عندها المشكلة
مثلًا الدنمارك عندهم اليوم وصل إلى أربعة وسبعين سنة
لكن للي داخلين الجدد في سوق العمل
أربعة وسبعين سنة حتى...
اليوم إذا عمرك اثنين وعشرين سنة في الدنمارك
ترى تقاعدك أربعة وسبعين
في هولندا واحد وسبعين للمشترك الجديد
في أمريكا سبعين
في أمريكا سنُّوا نظام
اللي هو من خمسة وستين إلى سبعة وستين حسب عمرك
ثم بعد ذلك أضافوا الاختياري إلى سبعين ثم...
فالفكرة أن كل الدول صارت ترفع سن التقاعد
بس الجميل في الموضوع أنه يكون بالتدريج
ما يرفعوا سن التقاعد مرة واحدة
خلاص بكرة ترى سن التقاعد خمسة وستين
معناته أنه إذا أنك متقاعدـ تراك بتعمل خمس سنوات
اللي على وشك التقاعد؟
لا، ما يتم في هذه الصورة
أقرب مثال، عُمان
عُمان رفعوا سن التقاعد من ستين إلى خمسة وستين
قبل ستة شهور، رفعوه بشكل تدريجي
بمعنى أنه السنة الأولى اليوم فعالة
خلاص اليوم سن التقاعد واحد وستين
بعد سبع سنوات يصير اثنين وستين
بعد سبع سنوات ثلاثة وستين
فاللي اليوم ثمانية وعشرين سنة
اللي باقي على خدمته ثمانية وعشرين سنة
هو اللي بيلحق على الخمسة وستين
دائمًا تغيرات التقاعد تصير بالتدريج وهذا مرَّة مهم
أني أنا واحد متقاعد المفترض أن حقوقي المكتسبة ما تمس أولًا
المتقاعد اليوم اللي يجيه راتب تقاعد
حتى لو كان بناءً على معادلة غير عادلة
ما لها علاقة في الموضوع
صعبه تيجي واحد متقاعد يأخذ راتب
فجأة الشهر الجاي نازل راتبه 20% ما هو منطقي
فهذا شيء دائمًا الحقوق المكتسبة في نظام التقاعد ما تمس
نفس الشيء المشترك اللي له اشتراكات سابقة طويلة
برضو اشترك فيها وحصلها بناء على النظام السابق
فصعب أنك تغير فيها بشكل...
الأمر الآخر اللي على وشك التقاعد
حتى سبعة إلى عشرة سنوات
برضو إذا بيصير في تغيير إما ما يصير في تغيير يمسهم تمامًا
أو تغييرات طفيفة بسيطة
لكن عادةً احنا واللي بعدنا
لا بد هذا هو اللي...
احنا عندنا ثمانية وخمسين؟
ثمانية وخمسين إي
ثمانية وخمسين بالميلادي يعني يجي ستين
فالفكرة أن التغيرات التدريجية
أبوظبي سن التقاعد لما رُفع من خمسة وأربعين إلى خمسة وخمسين
على مدى عشرين سنة
كل سنة يزيد ستة شهور سن التقاعد المبكر
مع أنه المفترض في هذا القياس أنه على طول في نفس اليوم
خمسة وأربعين لسَّه يعني
ما أدري تتقاعد أيش تسوي؟
100%
غير أثره الاقتصادي على البلد
من الناحية الإنتاجية، أثره سلبي ما في شك
لكن الواقع أنه إما أحد يتقاعد لأنه ما يحتاج يعمل
لأن عنده ملاءة مالية كافية
أو وهو الغالب في تصوري أنه يعمل في أعمال أخرى
هو فعليًّا ما تقاعد
بس أنه يأخذ فلوس تقاعد
هو فعليًّا ما تقاعد لكنه نظاميًّا متقاعد، ويأخذ راتب
فهذا برضو له أثر
قلنا لموضوع رفع سن التقاعد
أبوظبي مثلًا رفعت الاشتراكات من 20% إلى 26%
لكن رفعتها فقط على الداخلين الجدد لسوق العمل
اللي اليوم مشترك ما يلحقه شيء
عُمان رفعتها 1%
كم صار؟
في عُمان أعتقد صار 12.5 أو 12.6
ما زال قليل
هو لما يصير اشتراك قليل يصير التقاعد...
هي معادلة زي ما قلت لك قبل شوي
وفي بعض الدول تتجه إلى أنه لا...
مثلًا في إيطاليا، نسبة الاشتراك فيها 33%
فهي ترفع لك الاشتراك ليش؟
لأنها تبغى تقاعدك يصير زِين
فتأخذ 33% من راتبك؟
من راتبك، إي
طبعًا، ثلاثين مشترك بين المشترك عفوًا والجهة
في أمريكا أعتقد حوالي 5%
منخفض مرَّة، لكن ليش؟ زي ما قلنا قبل شوي
أنه ما يعطيك إلَّا 39%
فهو إذا انخفض هذا ينخفض هذا
في إيطاليا أتوقع تعطيك 83% أو شيء زي كذا صح؟
تعطي أعتقد أنه حول 70% كمعدل
طبعًا بإيطاليا النظام اللي هو الحصالة
فالحصالة، هل هو إجباري ثلاثة وثلاثين؟
إجباري إي
يحولون حصالة ولازم تشترك
لأنه الاشتراك إجباري لأنه لو ما كان إجباري
كثير ناس ما راح يشتركون
لأن الناس تناظر أنا بدفع اليوم، ما يهمني أنا بس أتقاعد أيش راح صير وضعي
كتأثير سلوكي
وبعدين الحكومة هي اللي تتورط في الأخير
بالضبط
فالحل الآخر، عندنا واحد: رفع سن التقاعد؟
إي رفع سن التقاعد
ممكن على المشتركين الجداد رفع في الاشتراكات
أحيانًا في حساب التقاعد لكن ما هو...
ترى حساب التقاعد
في إشكالية ثانية عندنا اللي هو لما بُني النظام
كان المتقاعدين متوسط الأعمار منخفض اللي هو ستة وخمسين سنة
صح
اليوم زاد بعد التقاعد صارت المدة أطول فهذا معناته
أنه برضو المتقاعد، المفترض راتبه يربط بالتضخم
المفترض المتقاعد راتبه يزيد
طيب هذا إصلاح ممكن يأثر على الاستدامة المالية
لكنه إصلاح منطقي لأن اليوم صار المتقاعد يعيش فترة أطول
فالمفترض أن راتبه يربط بالتضخم لتعويض انخفاض القوة الشرائية
لكن أنا أقصد لأنه الهدف في النهاية أنك توازن ما بين استدامة مالية
وبين خلينا نقول حياة كريمة للمتقاعد
فهذا من ضمن الإصلاحات مثل ربطه مع التضخم
إتاحة خيار الاستمرار في العمل في التقاعد
اليوم مثلًا بعضهم التقاعد إجباري على ستين سنة هجري
طيب أنا أبغى أكمل خمسة وستين سنة
ممنوع؟
ممنوع
يسمح فقط للقضاة والوزراء أعتقد
وأعضاء هيئة التدريس لكم سنة
بالنظام ممنوع
لكن أكثر الدول تتيح لك تكمل خمس سنين، وأعطيك عليها مكافأة
أنت يهمك تبغى تعمل
أو يهمك أن راتب التقاعد يكون عالي
كمل خمس أو سبع سنوات، وخذ عليها مكافأة
بمعنى المكافأة كيف طريقتها؟
يقول لك عن كل سنة زيادة
أنا راح أزيدك مثلًا 5% من راتبك التقاعدي
اشتغلت خمسة سنوات، راتبك التقاعدي يزيد 25%
هذا يخدم الصندوق من ناحية أنه يعزز الاستدامة المالية
لأنه الواحد صار يشترك أكثر
وبنفس الوقت يخدم الاقتصاد لأنه إنتاجية أكبر
وأيضًا، أنت تحتك خيار للمتقاعد اللي يبغى
اللي ما يبغى بسلامته
ونفس الشيء التقاعد المبكر ما هو ضروري ألغيه
ممكن يطبقون نسبة الخصم
التقاعد المبكر خليه متاح للي بيتقاعد مبكر
لكن افرض عليه نسبة خصم
بمعنى أنه مثلًا عن كل سنة أنا بتقاعد
فيه نسبة خصم من راتبي التقاعدي 2% مثلًا عن كل سنة
مثلًا تقاعدت بالسبعة وخمسين سنة
باقي ثلاث سنوات على التقاعد
يخصم من راتبي التقاعدي 6%
يكون خيار اللي يبي يتقاعد، يتقاعد
لكنه يحفز الناس أنها ما تتقاعد، وتكمل إذا أحبَّت
فإتاحة الخيارات هذا مفيد من ناحية الاستدامة المالية
ومفيد من ناحية تنوع الخيارات للواحد
أنه ما يُفرض عليه أحكام معينة
أيضًًا التدرج، موضوع التدرج مرَّة مهم
أنه ما يكون تغيُّر مباشر
لا بد الواحد يكون يعني...
مثلما قلنا مثال عُمان، صار في تدرج في التغيير
وأبوظبي، ومعظم دول العالم
وهذا أعتقد ترى من الأشياء اللي شوي
ما فُهمت بشكل جيد
الناس تتوقع لو بصير تغير بالتقاعد بيصير على الجميع مرة واحدة
لا الوضع ما هو كذا
الوضع بيكون في جانب كبير لمراعاة أثره على الناس
وأثره على الاقتصاد
في النهاية أصلًا المغزى من النظام كله
هو الحماية الاجتماعية، وتوفير دخل جيد للمتقاعدين
فما راح يصير اللي حصل في الدول عادة يكون فيه تدرج
رفع سن التقاعد يكون فيه تدرج
اللي على وشك التقاعد لا يمسه شيء وهكذا
أيضًا في اعتبارات مثلًا...
وهنا نقطة اللي يسمونها نظام التغيير التلقائي
في كثير من الدول مثل إيطاليا وفنلندا
عندهم نظام يسمونه آلية التعديل التلقائي
اللي هو سن التقاعد اليوم مثلًا عندهم خمسة وستين سنة
السنة الجاية مثلًا هيئة الإحصاء
قالت متوسط الأعمار زاد من ستة وسبعين إلى سبعة وسبعين
زاد سنة متوسط الأعمار، سن التقاعد يزيد شهر
تلقائيًّا؟
تلقائيًّا
النظام يغير بشكل تلقائي
في بعض الدول تراجعه بأحكام النظام زي عُمان
عُمان كل خمس سنوات لا بد تراجع سن التقاعد
وتراجع سن التقاعد بناءً على التغير في متوسط الأعمار في البلد
واحنا نراجعه كل كم؟
احنا ما في مراجعة
آخر شيء كان في السبعينيات؟
آخر شيء...
السؤال ممتاز
طبعًا احنا في مراجعة اكتوارية كل ثلاث سنوات
لكن نحكي أحكام نظام، ما في مراجعة
صار في مراجعة في عام 1421 تم تشكيل لجنة وزاريَّة
لإصلاح أنظمة التقاعد، يمكن لها أربعة وعشرين سنة
لكن المخرج اللي صار في وقتها
أن التأمينات الاجتماعية السابقة ما كان فيها تقاعد مبكر فقط
كان فقط موجودة في التقاعد
فأضافوه للتأمينات الاجتماعية
كان المقترح أنه يلغى من التقاعد المبكر
فأضيف في التأمينات الاجتماعية
وعلى فكرة هذا ما هو حديث اليوم
ترى في دكتور نسيت اسمه الأول لكن عائلته «الدسوقي»
كان أستاذ في جامعة الملك سعود
كتب ورقة في عام 1990
عن إصلاح أنظمة التقاعد
وأعطى نفس المقترحات نفس سن التقاعد
التقاعد المبكر
كل الكلام اللي قاعدين نقوله اليوم، هو قاله عام 1990
فهو ما هو موضوع جديد
هذا بالنسبة لموضوع الإصلاحات التي تتم بشكل تدريجي
وبالتغيرات ويمكن أفضل مثال عليه اللي هو «ساند»
«ساند» لما أُقر كان 2%
لكن بعد فترة اكتشفوا أن 2% كثير
أنه ما عندنا، الحمد لله، بطالة باللي كنا متصورينه
فخفضوه إلى 1.5%
هذا النوع من المراجعة هو النوع اللي نقصده
ما هو المقصود ترى المراجعة دائمًا
ترى بيصير ما هو بصالح الواحد أو ترى تصير بنشتغل أكثر
لا يمكن يصير العكس، تشتغل أقل
لأنه والله معدل الخصوبة لاحقًا تغير
اليوم مثلًا انخراط المرأة في سوق العمل
المفهوم السابق كان أنه إذا المرأة انخرطت في سوق العمل
معدل الخصوبة ينخفض بسبب أن خلاص المرأة تنشغل في عملها
لكن في دراسة طلعت مؤخرًا واللي اكتشفت العكس
أيش؟
أن انخراط المرأة في سوق العمل يُعكس على معدل خصوبة أعلى
هذه دراسة سعودية وللا؟
لا، دراسة على مجموعة دول
فالفكرة أنه دائمًا التغيرات الاقتصادية
والتغيرات السلوكية يصعب جدًّا التنبؤ فيها
صحيح
فلو تغير بعدين سواءً لصالح النظام أو ما...
يتم التغيير بناءً على أننا نحافظ على استدامة مالية مستمرة
أيضًا موضوع الأعمال الشاقة دائمًا تستثنى
بعض الأحيان الواحد يقول شلون أعمل وعمري خمسة وستين سنة
الأعمال الشاقة دائمًا تستثنى
والأعمال الشاقة ما هو بالضرورة أنه شغل مناجم ولا...
يمكن مهن مثل التمريض
لاحظت أنا رقم شد اهتمامي في تقرير السنة الماضية
للمؤسسة العامة للتنمية الاجتماعية
اللي هو المعلمين، متوسط تقاعد المعلمين اثنين وخمسين سنة
وموظفين الحكومة عمومًا ثمانية وخمسين سنة تقريبًا
فالمعلمين عندنا يتقاعدون قبل ست سنوات
هذا مفهوم لأن عملية التعليم شوي مُنهكة
ممكن من تجربة درست في فترة
ست سنوات جالس وتشرح
تعادل خمسة عشر ساعة جالس على المكتب
هذا وأنت تدرس بالغين عاقلين، تخيل تدرس أطفال
صحيح، فالعملية شوي متعبة فهذا ممكن يراعى
وفيه لجان تجتمع في العادة معظم الدول يصير عندهم لجنة
تجتمع كل سنة تحدد أيش الأعمال الشاقة
وكم سن التقاعد لكل مهنة؟
وهذا وجد عندنا أيام «ساند»
ترى «ساند» لما صارت الجائحة والتعويضات صار فيه لجنة
تدرس موضوع أيش المهن اللي تستثنى والمهن اللي تعطى وهكذا
أيضًا من أهم الإصلاحات للموضوع
دعم لبرامج الركيز الثالثة يسموها اللي هو التقاعد الاختياري
أو أنظمة التقاعد الاختياري
احنا اليوم، التغيرات الديموغرافية هذه كلها قاعدة تُنبئ
أن راتب المتقاعد اللي اليوم يدرس في الجامعة والثانوي
توه ما بعد دخل سوق العمل
هذا غالبًا إذا جاء وقت تقاعده
راح يصير أقل من معظم تقاعد اليوم
هذا يؤكد على أهمية أنه يصير في نظام تقاعد اختياري
يشترك فيه المشترك اللي يحب اختياريًّا
وتدفع الجهة، والحكومة تدعم هذا النظام
وبالتالي حتى إذا جاء وقت التقاعد
ويعوض النقص اللي بيصير في أنظمة التقاعد
وهذا هو اللي الآن صار نظام شائع جدًّا
معظم الدول اللي ما حولت لنظام الحصالة
وأبقت النظام التكافلي
أضافت الركيزة الثالثة، أضافت نظام تقاعد اختياري
صاروا الناس في نظام الحكومي اللي يعطيك حد معقول
وفي النظام الاختياري اللي يعطيك مساحة أكبر
أنت تشترك فيه، وتدفع زيادة على المستقطع علشان تأخذ راتب أعلى
علشان تأخذ راتب تقاعدي أعلى
الحين أنا حاسس عندي مشاكل كثيرة
ما هو مشاكل، عندي شوية ملاحظات يمين ويسار
وعليها بنتناقش
مثلًا يجي واحد أول شيء الدراسة اللي قلت لي صارت
أو الورقة البحثية اللي سواها، كانت عام 1990 قلت؟
إي، 1990
1990 إلى عام 2023، واحنا على أبواب 2024
وأنتم تقولون نفس الكلام، والواقع يقول غير الكلام
فإما أنكم تقولوا كلام ما هو صح
أو أنهم يسوون شغل ما هو صح
خصوصًا أنكم ما غيرتوا الكلام
يمكن أنكم بس تأخذون كلام اللي على الورق
فالتنظير يختلف عن واقع الحياة
ممتاز، أعتقد السؤال مرَّة ممتاز
الفكرة، طبعًا هو نفس الكلام ولا تغير شيء، صح؟
لأن اللي يتكلم عام 1990
دائما يتكلم عن موضوع الاستدامة المالية
ستين أو سبعين سنة قدام
فإلى الآن ما طلعت آثار كلامه
طبعًا في آثار كلامه اليوم اللي هو زيادة العجز
العجز اليوم إذا قلنا أنه 800 مليار
1990 يمكنه كان 40 مليار
فالتأخر هذا كله قاعد يوسع فجوة العجز
وغير كذا لو تم الإصلاح في 1990
يمكن أحتاج أني أرفع سن التقاعد مثلًا من ستين هجرية
أخليها ثلاثة وستين هجرية
اللي تعادل واحد وستين سنة ميلادية
هذا خلاص كفَّاني إلى اليوم خلاص بطَّل عجز
كم ممكن لو زاد هذا الفرق البسيط يكون عجز...؟
طبعًا ما نقدر نعرف
تقريبًا
بس أنه بيأثر تأثير جوهري
ممكن نقول 200 مليار؟
وغير كذا التقاعد مبكر
احنا لو التقاعد المبكر فقط ما فُرض في عام 1921
بيفرق كثير حتى
نسبة متقاعدي المبكر وقت اتخاذ القرار هذا
كان 11% اليوم تقريبًا 46%
إي
وهذا آثاره ما هي ملموسة، ولا هي محسوسة
إلا في أسفل القوام المالية اللي هو العجز الاكتواري
لكن هذا متى يبين؟
إذا لا قدر الله، وأنا ما أعتقد أنه راح يصير
إنه إذا اضطر، يمكن نتكلم بعد ثلاثين سنة
لو ما صار تغيير خلاص، الوضع لازم تحول نظام الحصالة
ولازم تخصص 15-20% من ميزانيتك
لدعم الفجوة هذه إلى الأبد
تستمر معك الفجوة هذه إلى أن يموتوا الجيل هذا كله يروح
عرفت قصدي
بس هذا أتكلم عن شيء افتراضي بعد ثلاثين سنة
مستحيل يصير
طيب لكن أنا أجيبها على سياق
أن ليش هم كانوا يتكلموا الاقتصاديين من 1990
تكلموا هذا الكلام ولا صار شيء إلى الآن، فقط للتوضح
فيه نقطة ثانية اللي هو فعليًّا صعب حله
فمثلًا لما تجي تقول أن التعليم
والتعليم ممكن أنا أنقص حتى سن التقاعد
بس في نفس الوقت هو التعليم اللي جالس يأخذ كل الميزانية
سواءً هنا أو هنا، فهو يأخذ ميزانية الدولة أو الميزانية العامة
كم أتوقع 20% منها للتعليم؟
تقريبًا
وأتوقع يمكن 80% من مخصص التعليم على رواتب المعلمين
احنا نتكلم عن ممكن ما أدري كم
مئات المليارات سنويًّا لرواتب المعلمين
وبرضو هم في التأمينات اللي بعدين بيرجعون يأخذونهم
أيش ممكن تسوي أصلًا في هذه الحالة؟
فأنت عندك هذه الحاجة من التعليم
اللي أنت تبغى تعلم الناس
وفي الأخير هم اللي بيأخذون
وهي مسألة الحكومة لازم تلعب باليدين في المكان هذا
لأجل تعليم الناس، فما يمديك تشيله، هذا واحد
اثنين: في نقطة اللي هي أنه ممكن تزيد في الميزانية العامة بعدين
بما أنه أنت قلت أنه مع الوقت أنه بتصير
ممكن في الميزانية يصير بند اللي هو التنميات الاجتماعية
يصير عادي أحس يمكن يصير منطقي
أن يكون فيه بند التنميات الاجتماعية
لأن بند التعليم بيقل لأنه عدد الطلاب قل
لا، زاد
ليش؟
ترى احنا كأجيال كنمو ترى يزود
لما نقول احنا كمتقاعدين
احنا عددنا بيكون لما قلت 40% من المشتركين
لكنه في نفس الوقت
الجيل اللي بعدنا ترى ضعفين ونص عددًا
لكن التغير فيه نسبة النمو، وحدَّة النمو
ولا عدد الطلاب لا بيصير يمكن ضعفين عدد طلاب اليوم
إلا صح، ما أدري شلون حسبتها
بس لأنه جاء في بالي أن كل اثنين
بس أنه في الأخير أصلهم سبعة جابوا اثنين صاروا أربعة عشر
فالتغيُّر في معدل النمو
وللَّا بيظل النمو، وبيصير أكبر
في نقطة اللي هي
كنت برجع لها قبل شوي، يوم كنا نتكلم على موضوع...
أن اليوم أنا أشعر أن التغييرات هذه، زي ما قلت قبل شوي
أن أكثر الناس حساسة لأي كلام يصدر في هذا السياق
مع أن أعتقد أن كل الناس تبغى التغيير هذا
ما أحد يبغى التغيير
لا كل الناس تبغي التغيير، بس ما أحد يدري
شلون؟ لأن أول شيء
من اللي أكثر الناس اليوم حساس لموضوع التغيير؟
دائمًا في المجالس لو تكلمت أنا عن الموضوع يتكهربوا
على موضوع تغيير التأمينات الاجتماعية
التقاعد إي، أنظمة التقاعد والتأمينات
وحتى في تويتر نشوف
مين؟
أول شيء المتقاعدين، هذا قلنا ما راح يمسه شيء
ما راح يمسه، المتقاعد لا تكتب ولا شيء خلّك
فالرجال هذا أو المتقاعد
هو يبي التقاعد لأنه ما رح يتأثر
وفي نفس الوقت، يهمه مصلحة أبناءه وأحفاده فهو يبغاه
بس بدون...
الثاني اللي على وشك التقاعد، وهذه هي أكثر فئة ومعها حق
لأن أنا فعلًا مرتب أموري
بتقاعد ومزين أموري، ومزبط لي استراحة
ومسوي لي شيء ثم فجأة واحد دخل، عرفت؟
تبقى الاستراحة عظم
هنا الفكرة لا بد أن يأخذ بعين الاعتبار، أن هذا ما راح أصلًا يمس
هو يتصور أنه لو تغيرت أنظمة التقاعد
أنه لا بتكمل، إن شاء الله، الاستراحة والأمور طيبة
بتتقاعد في الوقت اللي مخطط له
لأن عادةً كل أنظمة التقاعد لا تمس اللي قريب من التقاعد
واللي مخطط أموره، والحقوق المكتسبة لا تمس
فهو أصلًا فعليًّا في مصلحته لأنه في النهاية هو ما راح يتأثر
ولكن رح يتأثر إيجابًا لعياله وأحفاده
فيه يمكن جيل الأربعين أو أقل هذا هم اللي فعليًّا بيتأثروا
واللي بيصير فيه شوي حدَّة التأثر أكثر من غيرهم
لكن التأثير اليوم ممكن يصير طفيف
بدال ما تشتغل للستين يشتغل للأربعة وستين أو ثلاثة وستين
لكن ما راح تغير المعاشات التقاعدية بشكل كبير
بالعكس يربط بالتضخم
ويمكن يصير في أشياء خليني أقول منطقية لحد كبير
لكن لو ما صار هذا الشيء
ترى يمكن تيجي بعدين وضع معاشك يروح نصفه
لو تأخرنا تقريبًا ثلاثين أو أربعين سنة
يمكن في نصف مرحلة التقاعد
يصير في إشكالات في نظام التقاعد
ينخفض معاشك يصير أي شيء
بسبب التراكم هذا اللي حصل
فاحنا نرغب في التغيير لصالحنا احنا
في اللي باقي ما دخلوا
في اللي باقي ما دخلوا، وهذا بيصير عليهم
أكثر نوع من التأثر بيصير عليهم بدون شك
لكن برضو...
لو ما يصير عندهم تقاعد أصلًا
إي خلاص يروح لنظام الحصالة
إذا راح لنظام الحصالة هنا بيصير حتى عليه النظام أسوأ
لو راح للنظام التكافلي بأحكام أقل
بيكون أهون إلى حد كبير من لو حوَّل للنظام التكافلي بشكل كامل
في عندنا أحس أني أنا بتفق معك
أصلًا ما أعرف من وين جاء اللي هو سن التقاعد
ليش الإنسان يتقاعد أصلًا؟
المفترض أنه يشتغل طول حياته
ترى هو بدأ في عام ثلاثة عشر قبل الميلاد
الإمبراطور الروماني «أقسطس»
ثلاثة عشر قبل الميلاد؟
ثلاثة عشر قبل الميلاد يوم التقاعد بدأ إي
طبعًا التطبيقات هنا وهناك، ما هو بشيء...
أيش كان يسوي الأستاذ «رومان»؟
كان يعطي التقاعد طبعًا للجيش، للمتقاعدين من الجيش
خلاص وصل لمرحلة معينة ما يقدر يحارب
هو أصلًا كل حياته وعمره يشتغل في الجيش، يخدم الجيش
فما قدر يبني مهنة، يقدر يورثها لعياله
ففي النهاية هو تقاعد، يجي يقول تعال يا أمبراطور خدمتك كل عمري
الحين ما عاد عندي شيء، ولا أقدر الحين أحارب معك
فسن لهم نظام التقاعد
صار اللي يشتغل في الجيش اليوم وهكذا
لكن أشهر تطبيق صار في عام 1875
لشركة «أمريكا إكسبيرس»
هي اللي أول وحدة بدأت نظام التقاعد الحديث
الدول بدأت تدخل فيه من الثلاثينيات والعشرينيات والأربعينيات الميلادية
بشكل نظام التقاعد الحديث اللي احنا نعرفه اليوم
فالإنسان يتقاعد ضروري لأنه يصل مرحلة معينة
ما عاد يستطيع أن يؤدِّي عمله بالشكل المطلوب
يعني حتى هو نوع، البلد اللي...
ميزة كبيرة للسعودية والخليج أن الواحد يتقاعد بعمر ثمانية وخمسين ميلادي
هذا شيء ينم عن مستوى رفاهية عالي جدًّا في البلد
في الدنمارك يشتغل إلى أربعة وسبعين سنة
في أمريكا سبعة وستين سنة
ترى أمريكا عندهم يتقاعدون مبكرًا بالمناسبة
كم عندهم؟
التقاعد المبكر بس يبدأ من عمر اثنين وستين
وعليه نسبة خصم
فالفكرة أنه...
طبعًا نتفق أن أمريكا أسوأ مثال المفترض أن ما أحد يفكر فيها
لا ما هو بالضرورة
أنا أقصد كل الدول اضطرت تغير لأنه أصلًا
لو تشوف كل الدول تاريخيًّا
وهذا بالمناسبة موجودة في التقرير اللي أشرت له قبل شوي
«المعاش التقاعدي في لمحة»
في جدول يعرض لك الدول
كيف كان شكلها الديموغرافي عام 1940 وكيف شكلها اليوم
هذا بنحطه في نشرة الحلقة
ممتاز، هذا كلهم كل الدول تغير ديموغرافيًّا
فهذا هو السبب اللي خلّى كل الدول بدأت تتغير
ومتى الدول بدأت تتغير؟ من ثلاثين سنة
بس ليش؟ لأنهم بادئين قبلنا بثلاثين سنة
بس أن أمريكا نظامها سيء جدًّا
25% من الناس ما عندهم مدخرات لما يتقاعدون
ما عندهم أصلًا ولا شيء
الضمان الاجتماعي حقهم سيء جدًّا ما يعطيك حتى حد الكفاف
أغلب الناس، الظاهر 50% من الناس ما يدفعون
لأجل أنه يستثمر في...
الناس لا تستثمر في مستقبلها
الناس لا تستطيع التنبؤ بمستقبلها
الناس ما تهتم للأجيال الجاية
الناس لا تهتم
لما يتكلمون عن التغير المناخي مثلًا، ترى آخر همي
صحيح
لأنِّي أنا ما...
أنت تقول الأرض ترى بتتدمر، يقول لك ما لي دخل
ما يقدر الإنسان، زي حتى السرطان اللي يمسه مباشرةً
تقول له ترى الأكل أو نمط حياتك سيزيد نسبة حصول السرطان فيك
هو ما يسوي شيء ما يغير
فما بالك تقول بس بالله ادِّخر عشان...
ما راح يسوي
أنا فهمتك الآن
فأمريكا فيها مأساه ضخمة جدًّا
ما في مقارنة بين دول أوربا والدول الاسكندنافية
مختلف تمامًا
لكن الشاهد على مثالك من ضمن النماذج أو المنتجات المالية
ما ودِّي أقول شائعة بس الموجودة في أمريكا
يشترك فيها سنويًّا 50 ألف مواطن أمريكي
اللي يسمونها التمويل العقاري العكسي
أيش فكرة هذا؟ هو الرجال تقاعد
جاء عمره خمسة وسبعين أو ثمانين
كل مدخراته راحت
تقاعده أصلًا كان هو جزء كبير منه جاء من الـ«401 كيه»
اللي هو الاختياري، إذا عنده «401 كيه»
وهذا خلاص ما يستوي معاك للأبد خلاص تخلص حصالة
فالآن أيش يسوي؟ يروح يبيع بيته
يبيع بيته على مؤسسات مالية
تيجي المؤسسة المالية
طبعًا يبيع بيته بشرط أنه يجلس فيه إلى أن يموت
فتيجي المؤسسة المالية تشوف البيت
تقيم البيت من حيث حداثته، والحي
والأرض
وتقيّم الرجال
كم باقي يموت
كم باقي له يموت لأن هذا يفرق بالسعر
وتعطيه فلوس شهريًّا، إلى أن يموت
شهريًّا أو تعطيه مرة واحدة
يكيشه مرة واحدة، ويأخذ المبلغ
ويستثمر جزء منه ويرهنه لهم، ومباشرة يتوفى
وزي ما قلت قبل شوية
أنت تقول الناس ما تكترث، هو قاعد يقول خلاص ما عليه تروح للورثة
خليني أعيش أستمتع فيه أنا الآن وبعدها...
هذا النظام سيء، أحس أن الرأس مالية في شكلها الفج
هي المفترض أنه ما هو مثال
لا طبعًا أنا أجيبها كشاهد فقط إلى أي مدى الأمور توصل
ما هو مثال، احنا نطمح أن احنا ما نصل إلى هذا المستوى
لأن أنظمة الحماية الاجتماعية لازم تصير أنظمة قوية جدًّا
وأنظمة خلينا نقول مستدامة
والحكومة القادمة تدعمها على طول الوقت
لأنها تنعكس بشكل كبير على رفاهية المواطن
في أكثر أوقات اللي المواطن يحتاج فيها مجتمعه، وبلده
بس لما أقول لا للتقاعد
صدقني أنا ما أعرف ليش الناس يتقاعدون
صحيح، أنه هناك أعمال شاقة وفي الجيش
في أماكن يحتاج أنك تكون أما بطاقتك القسوى أو أني ما أبغاك
بس الأماكن المكتبية، واللي هي أغلب الأعمال
الأماكن البسيطة، ليش الواحد يتقاعد؟
الناس لما تتقاعد تخيل باقي عشرين سنة، كثير أنك ما تشتغل
أبغى أعطيك ثلاث سنين عشان تحس أن التقاعد سيء بعدين ارجع للعمل
وفي دراسة ترى حتى على انعكاس العمل
في فترة التقاعد هذه على الصحة النفسية، والجسدية
شيء غير عادي، انعكاس إيجابي جدًّا
واليوم نشوف كثير من المسؤولين يوصل أعمارهم في السبعين وفوقها
كثير من رجال الأعمال أعمارهم يمكن بعضهم يتجاوز الثمانين
ويداوم كل يوم في المكتب، ويتابع أعماله
طبعًا هذا الشيء هو شيء تفضيلي
يكون اختياري لكن صعب الدولة تيجي تفرضه على الجميع
الناس ما هي واحد
ما في مشكلة بس منطقي أنك ترفعه إذا...
في مستهدف أنه الظاهر 2030
برضو متوسط الأعمار يوصل إلى ثمانية وسبعين
فكل شيء جالس يرفع...
هو نتيجة
فمنطقي برضو أنك ترفعها، ثمانية وخمسين قليل مرة
قليل مرة يعني ثمانية وخمسين لسه...
بدأت تقتنع
لا أنا هذا مقتنع فيه، أنا أشوف المفترض ما يتقاعد الإنسان إلى أن يموت
ترى هذا..
يعني جدي...
كلهم كانوا يشتغلون إلى...
ما يجي وقت، يعني الإنسان ولد أنه يشتغل
عشان يحيى، ويأكل وزي كذا...
مو أنه يقعد، صدق ما هو منطقي أنك تقعد
أيش تسوي؟ ما فيه شيء بس قاعد في البيت
يعني تطفش وتصير أزمات، وتبدأ صحتك تتدهور
أحس أن في أشياء كثير
فأنا متفق معك إن كان بيزيد تكّة في التقاعد ما عندي مشكلة
بس إذا نأخذ الصورة الكبيرة
أنه واحد: ما في مشكلة أن يكون عند الخليج نظام رفاهية
زي ما نتكلم احنا عن الدول الاسكندنافية في الرفاهية اللي يعيشونها
فما هو عيب أن يكون في...
بالعكس، يمكن أنها تصير ميزة
بس ترى بتكلفة، الرفاهية هذه بتكلفة
تكلفة ضرائب دخل استثنائية في الدول الاسكندنافية
ضرائب استقطاع على التقاعد عالية جدًّا
ترى أعلى دول استقطاعات الدول الاسكندنافية
فالرفاهية طبعًا هي...
تأخذ وتعطي ما فيها
بس الشغلة الثانية أن هو تحدي الصدق
أن اللي تقوله كان زمان
اليوم أتوقع أن في تحديات جديدة مع مثلًا...
هل بنبقى زي ما احنا؟ هذا تحدي ترى
هل بيبقى أن الناس يدخلون سوق العمل؟
هل اللي بسوق العمل
بيكملون فترات طويلة ولا خلاص بيستغنى عنهم؟
طبيعة العمل، وخصوصًا مثلًا مع الذكاء الاصطناعي وغيره
في ناس اللي تطالب مثلًا بالدخل الأساسي العالمي
لما واحد يطالب يقول للناس لا تشتغلون أنا بعطيك
لا تشتغل، ولا بأخذ نسبة استقطاع ولا المواضيع هذه كلها
أنا بعطيك فلوس بس لا تشتغل
هذا من الأشياء النظرية، ما هي أشياء أعتقد أنها عملية أبدًا
هم يجيبونها في سياق ماذا لو صار وانتشرت الـ«إيه آي» وفعلًا...
بس ما أعتقد أنه شيء ممكن
أني بفرض ضريبة أكبر على الشركات اللي تستفيد من المنتجات هذه
وأرد أوزعها على الناس
ليش ما تعتقد؟
ما أدري، المقياس ما هو منطقي شوي
أعني أقصد ما أشعر أنا أنها...
ممكن تصير، بس ما هو بالصورة اللي الناس تتوقعها
وهذا الشيء، إذا...
يمكن يصير بالطريقة اللي هو صاير اليوم
اللي صاير اليوم كل دول العالم يسمونه الركيزة صفر
اللي هو فكرته زي فكرة الضمان الاجتماعي عندنا في السعودية
زي الحساب العالمي أعتقد في بريطانيا
كل دول العالم تقريبًا عندها أي أحد ما عنده ما يشتغل وعنده...
خلينا نقول إما ما يشتغل أو راتبه ضعيف
يصير في له دخل من الميزانية العامة للحكومة
من الضرائب اللي تأخذ بشكل عام
هذا موجود في كل دول العالم
إذا يقصدون شيء بهذا النوع فممكن هذا الشيء يصير
لكن هل بيصير بدرجة أو بقياس يسمح لي أن الأمور تصير مستدامة؟
هذا الشي اللي أنا أستبعده
فهي فكرة أن الاستدامة غير منطقية
غير موجودة في هذا الجانب
هو اللي بيصير أن الحكومات اللي عليها أن تسويه
أن هذا هو مكان أنت تدفع فيه، وتخسر فيه بدون نقاش
تدور وتربحهم في مكان ثاني
وبهذا كل الحلول هذه غير منطقية
اللي كنا نتكلم عنها هو الحلول أني أنا كيف أبغى أغطي العجز؟
هذا المنطقي، وللّا؟
ما عليه ترى ما فهمت
فكل حلول الحكومة أني أنا كيف أشتغل؟
أني أغطي أني أعطي الناس فلوس
بس ما يمديني أجيب، وكيف أخلّي الناس تدفع أكثر
ما هي سالفتي
راح يصير عجز
الضمان الاجتماعي أو التأمينات الاجتماعية
بتصير مصدر كلفة على الدولة
ما يمديها تكون مكان مستدام
وين تكون مكان مستدام؟ أنه تصير عندي أرباح كدولة من أماكن كثيرة
وتغطي هذا العجز اللي دائمًا موجود وسيزداد
شوف هذه، طبعًا كل الدول عندها التوجه هذا لأن اليوم
حتى لو تشوف مثلًا اللي قاعد يصير مثلًا في رؤية 2030
والقطاعات الجديدة، وعمل الاستثمارات العامة في خلق مشاريع جديدة
وكل هذه المستهدفات وفي النهاية أحاول أتجاوز الأشكال هذه
وأحاول أن ينمو الاقتصاد معي بشكل كبير
لأن في النهاية، كل دولة يعني لا يمكن دولة
نأخذ مثال على مستوى العالم
لا يمكن أن تصير دولة بمعنى دولة
ما تقدم تعليم وصحة وضمان اجتماعي
حد أدنى من الحماية الاجتماعية
هذا الشيء، الدولة مقدمته مقدمته
إذا عجزت عن ذلك عندها خيارات أنها تخفض العملة
تطبع وتسوي لها آثار سلبية مدمرة
لكن هي ما عندها خيار هذه الأشياء أساسية
فأعتقد هذا الشيء يمشي في السياق
قصدي يمكن أصلًا أن الحلول المنطقية هي أنه احنا كيف...
يعني هذه خلاص
بس كيف نقلل من العجز وأنه فعلًا بيكون شيء موجود
وخصوصًا مع التغيرات المستقبلية
هو ليس الفكرة الحد من العجز الاكتواري أنه 800 مليار نصفرها
ترى هذا ما هو أبدًا هدف
أنك تقلل تزايدها وتسارعها
تقلل تسارعها وتخفض منها إلى درجة تستطيع إدارتها
حتى ما هو من المنطقي أن أرجع أخليها صفر
وفي المقابل صحيح أنها تصبح استدامة مرة ممتازة
بس برضو لها آثار إجتماعية ولها آثار، وضحت الفكرة؟
فدائمًا المشرع يناظرها بأبعادها المختلفة
أبعادها الاجتماعية، والاقتصادية، حتى على وضع الأجور، وسوق العمل
يمكن لو أرفع الاشتركات راح أحل الاستدامة المالية
بس يمكن يرفع علي تكلفة الأجور للسعوديين
كل شيء له تبعاته
لكن الأكيدة والواضح لنا أنه فيه مشكلة وعجز ضخم
ولا بد أنه يعالج، وهذا صار لأسباب ديموغرافية بشكل رئيسي
وهنا دوره على المواطن وعلى المشترك نفسه
أن يبدأ يجهز من نفسه من الآن للتقاعد
ومن ناحية أنه يبدأ يستثمر بنفسه
يبدأ يحاول...
بس ليش الواحد يستثمر نفسه؟
أقصد أنه الواحد اليوم، خاصة الشباب
بغض النظر عن موضوع التقاعد
الواحد دائمًا يكون لا بد بأن يكون عنده نمط حياة
فيه ادخار وفيه استثمار لتقاعده
هذا الموضوع يتأكد أكثر اليوم عندنا في السعودية
ليش؟ لأن الجيل الجديد
ممكن ما يشوف الحاجة هذه لأنه شايف قدام عيونه
الجيل اللي سبقه أنه ما أحتاج لهذا الشيء
لأن وجود نظام تقاعد وتأمينات قوي
وبيعطي عوائد أو تقاعدات جيدة  لحد كبير
ما هو بحافز لها أن يبدأ يأخذ الخطوة
حتى يمكن ثقافة الادخار كلها ما تصير موجودة في البيت أساسًا
صح، ثقافة الادخار في السعودية...
جدًّا خفيفة
أحس أنها في تحسن بس إنها ضعيفة جدًّا
صحيح
لا شوف لها أسباب كبيرة
أول شيء عدم وجود الضرائب ترى له دور
ضرائب على الدخل
لأنه عادةً الادخار يعطي الحكومات تعطي حوافز عليه
مثلًا موضوع الثقافة ترى لها دور
موضوع مستوى نضج القطاع المالي
هذا برضو موضوع جدًّا مهم
أيش يعني؟
اليوم، لو نشوف السوق الأمريكي على سبيل المثال
أقصد بوجود نضوج مالي
أنه يكون عندي سوق مالي عميق
فيه شركات مالية مختلفة متنوعة
ومنتجات استثمارية متنوعة
هذا الشيء يفرق كثير في موضوع الادخار
في عندي أدوات ادخارية تساعدني أني أدخر
اليوم مثلًا برنامج سوق القطاع المالي
بوجود شركات التقنية المالية
اليوم في أكثر من مئتين شركة للتقنية المالية، متنوعة في منتجاتها
كل هذا التنوع يساعد أو يخلق فرصة لي
أني والله يمكن أربط راتبي ويستقطع 9% بشكل تلقائي
أني أشترك «بمدى» يستقطع مني بالبطاقة
يستقطع مني كل شهر مثلًا 10% من راتبي
الشغلات البسيطة هذه ترى تفرق
كثير من الناس تلقى عنده مبدأ أن يستقطع 10% من راتبه
يقدر يستقطع يمكن بعضهم راتبه يقعد 10% ما صرفها
لكن ما فيه أداة تخليه يأخذ الخطوة هذه
فوجود مثل شركات مثلًا تقنية مالية
تساعدك أن تأخذ هذه كلها تفرق في معادلة الادخار
ثم شوي تشيع ثقافة الادخار بين الناس بشكل تراكمي
أيش يفرق مع الواحد لو حط 10%؟
خلينا نأخذ مثال نفرض مثلًا «خالد»
«خالد» اشتغل، شوف ترى مثال شوي متحفظ
لماذا متحفظ؟ لأنه يشتغل براتب 5 آلاف
بدأ براتب 5 آلاف
عمره ثلاثة وعشرين سنة وتقاعد بعمر أربعة وستين سنة
هذا نتكلم عن اثنين وأربعين سنة
راتبه ينمو بـ3.5%
بدأ 5 آلاف ووصل 22 ألف
لو استقطع 10% من راتبه كل شهر ويستثمره
العائد الاستثماري برضو متحفظ 8%
هنا في نهاية الاستثمار
بيصير هو مجموع اللي استقطعه الـ10% هذه اللي يدفعها
كانت 555 ألف
لكن كم قيمتها وقت التقاعد؟
3 مليون، وضحت؟
في نقطة ثانية هنا
تخيل أنه لو مدَّها ثلاثة سنوات بس
لو مد المدَّة
بدال ما هو أربعة وستين مدَّها لسبعة وستين
كم الـ3 مليون بتصير؟ 4 مليون
المليون الأخير جاء...
قعد اثنين وأربعين سنة عشان يجيب 3 مليون
المليون الأخير جاء في ثلاث سنوات
ليش أقول الكلام هذا؟
لأنه من أهم الأمور أنك تستثمر مبكر
أنا أتذكر كتبت تغريدة اللي هو الاستثمار ما هو سالفة معقدة
الاستثمار باختصار خمسة أشياء
استثمر مبكرًا، فهذا أحد شواهد أنك تستثمر مبكر
ليش؟ لأن إذا استثمرت مبكر اليوم
السنة ما راح تفرق معك السنة القريبة هذه اللي أنت فيها
لكن السنة الأخيرة تفرق معك فرق كبير
فكلما بدأت مبكر كلما فرقت معك بشكل كبير
هذه الأولى، اللي هو استثمر مبكرًا
الثاني، استثمر باستمرار
برضو أعد استثمر توزيعاتك عشان تستفيد من العائد التراكمي
كذلك نوع استثماراتك في محاور منوعة
والخامسة: لا تبيع
خلينا نأخذها واحدة واحدة
أول شيء قلناه استثمار مبكر على موضوع...
لأنه الآن أيش اللي يفرق الـ500 ألف هذه والاستقطاع 10%
ليش صارت 3 مليون؟
عاملين، الأول: العائد اللي هو كان 8%
لو خلينا 10% في مثالنا، الـ3 مليون تصبح 5 مليون
العائد، واللي يفرق الثاني الزمن
العائد صعب إنك تديره
تعرف يعتمد على المخاطر وتغيرات الأسواق وغيرها
بس الزمن تقدر تديره
فدائمًا خلِّي الزمن صديقك
استثمر، واصبر، ولا تستعجل في البيع
خلِّي دائمًا خططك الاستثمارية على المدى البعيد
«وارن بافت» مثلًا
«وارن بافت» عمره الحين أعتقد ثلاثة وتسعين أو أربعة وتسعين
99% من ثروته تشكلت بعد عمر الخمسين
كل النمو اللي صار قبل الخمسين بشكل 1% من ثروته اليوم
فدائمًا الاستثمار على المدى البعيد
وهنا يجي التحدي لأن الواحد يقول التقاعد بعدين ما...
الواحد صعب أن يقتنع بهذه الفكرة
ولذلك لا بد له حوافز اللي هو الدفع مثلًا لأن اليوم...
كل الناس تعرف أن التدخين مضر
وكل الذين يدخنون يدرون أن تدخين مضر
بس هو يحتاج حوافز تساعده، نفس الشيء للادخار وغيره
أيضًا من ضمن الأمور اللي هو...
الواحد ثروته هي رأس ماله البشري، ورأس ماله المادي
اليوم عمره مثلًا ثلاثين سنة على سبيل المثال
واحد عمره ثلاثين سنة يشتغل مثلًا في القطاع المالي
ثروته هي الأصول اللي عنده سواءً محفظات أسهم
أو عقار وغيره أو صكوك ولا أيًّا كان
والأصل الثاني اللي هو رأس ماله البشري
اللي هو بيجيب له فلوس ثلاثين سنة قدام
فهو لو أخذ شهادة مثلًا يشتغل في القطاع المالي
وأخذ شهادة الـ«سي في إيه»
هذه تضمن له
في المتوسط دخله بيصير الضعف خلال السنوات الجاية
فمعناته كأن عنده أرض، وجاءه تثمين الضعف
ثم مع الوقت يبدأ يخفض رأس مالك البشري
الواحد كلما كبر في عمره وكلما زادت أصوله
فأنت فكرة الادخار أنك تأخذ من أصولك هذه
رأس مالك البشري وتوديه لمحفظتك
إلى رأس مالك المادي
لأن هذا هو اللي بيصرف عليك بعدين
اليوم رأس مالك البشري هو اللي قاعد يصرف عليك
مستقبلًا محفظتك بتصرف عليك، فهذه النقطة مرَّة مهمة
النقطة الثانية اللي هي استثمر باستمرار
فكرته أنه خليها عادة
استقطع كل شهر، لا تحقر مبلغ صغير
مهما فاض عندك مبلغ لو بسيط استثمره
لأن أثره بعدين بيصير كبير
وفيه مثال...
فيه الاسترىتيجية اللي يسموها توسيط التكلفة
خلينا نأخد مثال، مثلًا عبدالرحمن على سبيل المثال
تقول أنا عندي مبلغ كل شهر
عندي 5 آلاف ريال بحطها في السوق
السوق طالع أو نازل، سوق الأسهم
طالع أو نازل أو منخفض
في يوم التاسعة وعشرين تلقائيًّا يطلع من حسابي لهذا...
أنا عمر أقول: لا
أنا الـ5 آلاف هذه بحطها على جنب
وإذا نزل السوق 10% سأشتري فيها
وكل شهر أجمع الخمسة مع الخمسة وإذا وصلت مبلغ معين
إذا السوق وقتها كلما نزل، لو نزل 10% اشتريت
أداؤك بناءً على بيانات ستين سنة، إحدى الدراسات
أداؤك أفضل مني بكثير بأضعاف
أنا؟
إي اللي تشتري في القيمة
بس أنك تشتري في كل وقت
لأن السوق على مدى سنوات طويلة قاعد ينمو بشكل كبير
تشوف السوق الأمريكي 100 سنة
كله مع مستوى نمو، مع أنه صار فيه أزمات في النصف
وانهيارات على 60 أو 70%
بس ليش الاقتصادات تنمو، والشركات تنمو
في عام 1917 أكبر شركتين في العالم
«يو.أس ستييل» 46 مليار كان قيمتها
بعدها يجي «أمريكان تيلفون» تقريبًا 14 مليار دولار
يعني 14 مليار دولار و46 مليار دولار
اليوم أكبر شركة أبل، 3 تريليون
بعدها مايكروسوفت، 2.8 تريليون
بعدها أرامكو، تقريبًا 2.2 تريليون
فالفكرة أن الاقتصادات تنمو، فأنت...
والأسواق دائمًا في الغالب الأحوال صاعدة
فحاول أنك تخليها عادة مستمرة
وأنك تستثمر حتى مبالغ لو مبالغ...
وما تتعب رأسك
إي ولا تستذكي لأن بالعكس اللي يستذكي غالبًا يخسر
في تجربة مثيرة للاهتمام، ولطيفة
في روسيا في باحث جاب قردة
قردة اسمها «لوشا» جابها وحط قدامها ستين مكعب
المكعبات هذه فيها أسماء الشركات المدرجة في سوق الأسهم الروسي
وخلَّاها تروح تختار ثمانية مكعبات
جاءت القردة أخذت ثمانية مكعبات
أخذ الثمانية المكعبات هذه وحطها في محفظات أسهم
اشترى بها محفظة
بعد عشرة سنوات، تفوقت على أداء 93% من المضاربين في السوق
صحيح والله
هذه طبعًا في «بورتون مالكيل»
اللي هو أستاذ الاقتصاد في جامعة «برنستون»
عنده كتاب جميل اسمه «المشي العشوائي في وول ستريت»
اللي هو المشي العشوائي عنده فرضية هو
يقول الناس تمشي بشكل عشوائي، فهو يحاجج في المضاربين
والناس اللي يحاول يستذكي، زي ما تفضلت
أنه يحاولوا يبيع ويشتري، ويلقط السهم بسعر منخفض
«بورتون مالكيل» وكذلك «جون بوقل» اللي هو مؤسس «فانجارد»
يقولون أنه ما نعرف أحد، ولا نعرف أحد يعرف أحد
قدر يضارب باستمرار، ويحقق أرباح باستمرار
عملية في النهاية ترى خاسرة
فهم فرضيتهم يقولوا لك اشتري في السوق
وقفل الشاشة
حتى لو ما تبغى تقفل الشاشة
في دراسة شافت أن الناس اللي تفتح الشاشة كثير، وتتابع
بشركة وساطة شافت الدخول في كم فترة وكم...
اللي يدخلون دائمًا، ويتابعون الشاشة أداؤهم أقل من غيرهم
أقل من اللي قفلها
«فيديليتي» سوَّت دراسة من أكثر العملاء اللي عندهم حققوا آداء
طلعوا من؟
اللي ماتوا
فلذلك دائمًا...
عشان.. الدخل
زي الاكتتاب في فترة سابقة
فلذلك دائمًا...
لكن ليش الناس تحب المضاربة؟ ترى تحفز الدوبامين
هناك كتاب اسمه «أُمّة الدوبامين»
يحاول أن يفسر الكثير من الأشياء
إلى أن نشوة الدوبامين هي التي تقود لهذا الشيء
مثلًا المخدرات وممارسة الجنس وغيرها
كلها جاءت لأنها أصلًا في مستوى دوبامين عالي
فهو اللي يشتغلوا في القمار
عنده مستوى دوبامين عالي، ينتشي إذا ضبط معه الرهان
المضاربة فيه نوع من الأعراض هذه
أنه مع كثرة المضاربة يبدأ شوي يشعر بالنشوة هذه فيصير خلاص يدمنها
أعطيك مثال في أحد الدراسات
لقوا أنه من الناس اللي استمرت على المضاربة
حتى مع الخسائر، هو لأنه ما هو منطقي
واحد يخسر عشرة سنوات، وما يزال يضارب
لقوا هم الناس اللي أول ما دخلوا بدأوا في المضاربة كانوا يحققون أرباح
لأنه هو ضارب وراهن بناءً على معطيات معيّنة، وضبطت معاه
هو تصور أن رهانه ضبط بناءً على معطياته
مع أنه أصلًا المعطيات يمكن ما لها علاقة
صحيح
فأعطته نشوة، وبدأ هو يعتقد أن هذا الموضوع راح يتكرر مرة ثانية وثالثة
فهو يحاول يكررها إلى أن يوصلها
لكن الناس اللي بدأوا في المضاربة، وتفاجأوا في البداية خسارة بعد خسارة
هذا ما يكمل، على طول يطلع
وحتى في دائمًا في دراسات اجتماعية، وسلوكية كثير على...
طبعًا ما هم مضاربين أتكلم عن اللي يدخلون في القمار في الرهان
أسرهم ترى تتأذى منهم أذية غير عادية
تلقاه يقتِّر علينا، وهو رايح يراهن على خيل تسبق خيل
فهذا من ضمن الشغلات اللي الواحد يعني...
أنت قلت على سالفة أن لو تبغى تستثمر
باستثمار دائم هو فيها تحدي
أحس الميزة في التأمينات الاجتماعية
الحين ببدأ أحاول أربط بالاثنتين
التأمينات الاجتماعية أنك ما يمديك تسحب فلوسك
حتى لو كنت في أسوأ...
لو في الخيار هذا، أيش رأيك الناس بتسحب؟
أتوقع الناس بتسحب، على طول
كل الناس بتسحب
فالتحدي صدق في خيار أني أنا أسثمر فلوسي بنفسي
وأن ممكن تصير أزمة، وممكن أنك تروح تشتري سيارة
تروح تقول خليني بسحب شوي من هنا
ممكن تصير في حالة طارئة فتضطر أنك تسحب
بس أن السحب هو اللي يأثر في هذا واحد من التحديات
راح أجيك عليه
هذا ليش احنا نسمع ناس كثير
الناس كسبت في العقار
نسمع كثير والله فلان اشترى الأرض الفلانية بكذا
وطلعت كذا، بالذات الأرض الخام
ترى جزء كبير منه، لأنه أصلًا ما كان يقدر يبيعها
بالذات الأرض الخام ثقيلة، وصعبة
وفترة التسعينيات والثمانينيات أصلًا السوق كان ضعيف
فممكن تلاقيه، أحتفظ فيها مضطر ما هو خياره
ولو كان عنده خيار، يمكن طلع
صح
بدون ما أنه يكسر سعرها
فكثير منهم تتكون ثرواتهم من ناحية العقار ونشوفهم
لأنه قضية التخارج مثلًا قرار التخارج يصير أصعب
حتى ليش المستندات الاستثمارية أداءها أحسن من الأفراد
ترى من أحد التفسيرات، أن أداء الشركة الاستثمارية
لأنه في حوكمة
عشان تقرر قرار بيع هذه عملية تأخذ ثلاثة أسابيع أو أسبوعين
في لجنة ومجلس ودراسة
الفرد يفتح الشاشة ويبيع
فالقرارات السريعة هذه تخليه
ردّة فعله على الأخبار سريعة، وغير عقلانية
على ذكر العقار مثلًا نفترض أن أحد استثمر في العقار وللّا في الأسهم
بس عشان نشوف فكرة البيع
في الثمانينيات مثلًا أنا أتوقع ولا عندي بيانات
لكن أتوقع أن اللي يستثمر في الأسهم يحقق أكثر من العقار
وسأعطيك من الجزء اللي فيه بيانات
بس ليش احنا ما نشوفهم؟
لأن ما أحد يحتفظ غالبًا
اللي عنده حقق مبلغ معين باعه، واشترى له سيارة ولا شيء
البيانات الموجودة اليوم من عام تقريبًا 1998 إلى اليوم
هذا سوق السعودية؟
سوق السعودية بيانات «بلومبرق»
أنا قارنت بين ثلاثة أشياء
قارنت، أول واحد اشترى أرض في حي المروج
حي المروج منشور في جريدة في عام 1998
كان سعر المروج تقريبًا حدود 675 ريال
سعر المتر في حي المروج، عام 1998 ميلادي
2018 هجري تقريبًا
لو واحد اشترى أرض في المروج 500 متر
هذه بتطلع 337 الف
هذا خلنا نقول عبدالرحمن اشترى في المروج
أنا اشتريت في مصرف الراجحي، بعطيني المثال الزين
استثمرت في مصرف الراجحي اشتريت أسهم بنفس المبلغ
حسنا «أيمن» اشترى في «تاسي» سوق الأسم السعودي
المروج 337 ألف هذه صارت 2.9 مليون، 3 مليون إلا
«أيمن» تقريبًا 3.2 مليون
في «تاسي» سوق الأسهم السعودي يعني أعلى من المروج
طبعًا جزء كبير...
ولو هو بس استثنى الشركات الخاسرة اللي يسمونها الخشاش
كان رقم زاد بكثير
حتى مع اللي صار في 2006؟
حتى مع اللي صار في 2006
غير كذا أنا اللي دخلت في المحظوظ
اللي ما فيه أحد يقدر يسويه صعب الواحد يسوي هذا الشيء
اللي اختار الراجحي حقق عفوًا 8.5 مليون
8.5 مليون؟
8.5 مليون
أرض المروج 2.9 مليون، والراجحي 8.5 مليون
لا بالأسهم أنا أتفق معك
بس فيه واحد وراءك جالس يضحك
فهو بناءً على العائد التراكمي
في دراسة قريبة اليوم طلعت قبل شهرين
كانت تقارن ما بين، أيش أفضل تنويع في الاستثمارات؟
وبرجع لك بالنقطة هذه بنيجي على النقطة هذه
لقوا أفضل شيء يجيب عائد
أن تستثمر كل فلوسك في الأسهم، ما تحط صكوك وما تحط...
طبعًا أقصد هنا الصكوك الحكومية
صكوك الشركات بالذات الموجودة اليوم عندنا في المنصَّات
نظاميًّا مصنف صكوك بس فعليًّا هو الائتمان الخاص أكثر
زي مثلًا «دينار» والشركات هذه
فعليًّا هي شركات ائتمان خاص
دورها تعزل العائد أكثر من أن دورها يخفضها
لأننا الحين إذا جبنا نتكلم عن التقاعد
راح نتكلم في سياق أن الصكوك تخفض العائد، وضحت؟
بس في المقابل تعطيني ميزة تخفض علي المخاطر
وتعطيني أريحية في التدفقات النقدية
لأنه عندي في النظام التقاعدي حتى لو كان عندي مساهمة جيدة
أو نظام الحصالة عندي ناس قاعدين يأخذوا معاشات
فلازم أجدول لهم تدفقاتهم النقدية
هذا بالضرورة راح يُعكس على انخفاض العائدات
فعودة للدراسة اللي قبل شوي لقيت أفضل توليفة أن يكون...
شافته على ستة وثلاثين دولة
أفضل توليفة إن 35% من محفظتك في أسهم الدولة المحلية اللي عندك
والباقي في السوق العالمي
لكن طبعًا هذه فيها اقتطاع عالي شوي
لأن هي ما شافت، هي قاعدة تناظر بس استرىتيجية الصكوك والأسهم
الصكوك الحكومية أقصد
لأن في فرضية يقول لك 60% خليها أسهم 40% صكوك
في فرضية ثانية يقول لك خلي عمرك اللي هو 120 سنة
120 ناقص عمرك، هذا...
مثلًا عمرك أربعين سنة، 120 ناقص أربعين، ثمانين
خلاص 80% بالأسهم 20% صكوك حكومية
عشان تقلل المخاطر
مثلًا هذا واحد من الاسترىتيجيات
فهم يقارنوا بين هذه الاسترىتيجيات
طبيعي أن أفضل عائد يكون في الأسهم
لكن لما نشوف اليوم في الاستثمارات البديلة
مثلًا ما هي من ضمن الأشياء اللي تدخل في...
في الدراسات اللي نتكلم عنها، لأنها ما فيها نمذجة
ولا تقدر تدخلها في نماذج مالية
ما في مؤشر واضح يقدر يقيسها لك على مدّة زمنية طويلة
ولا فيها سيولة، لكن عادئها أفضل مثل العقار
مثل الملكية الخاصة، ومثل الائتمان الخاص
اللي هي منصات التمويل بالدَّين اللي تكلمنا عنها قبل شوي
فأفضل شيء توليفة طبعًا هو التنويع دائمًا
أنك لا تركز استثماراتك في استثمار واحد
التنويع ما بين الأصول
يكون عندك مثلًا أسهم، ويكون عندك عقار
يكون عندك الصكوك
ثم الاستثمارات هذه تستمر بمبالغ بسيطة دائم تنوع ما بينها
وهذا لما قلنا قبل شوي عمق القطاع المالي
وجود مستثمرين متنوعه يساعد على موضوع الادخار
لأن تنوع المنتجات سابقًا في العقار لازم يصير المبلغ كبير عشان تدخل
اليوم بـ1000 ريال تقدر تدخل في العقار
الصكوك من أول الحد الأدنى للشراء مليون ريال
اليوم الصكوك 1000 ريال
فهذا التنوع كله راح يفرق بشكل كبير على موضوع عملية الادخار
فإنك تنوع على مستوى المحفظة من ناحية مختلف الاصول
ثم بعد ذلك تنوّع على مستوى حتى داخل الأسهم
يعني أنك ما تستثمر مثلًا في شركة واحدة أو شركتين
تحاول تستخدم مثلًا الـ«إي تي أف» أو المؤشرات المالية
أو في قطاعات مختلفة أو شركات كبرى
مثلًا أبل
الراجحي مثلًا
رحت أبل
ما في «سابك» أو «أرامكوا» نروح السليم
حتى على سبيل المثال على سيرة أنك جبت المؤشرات يعني أبل
أنا قلت مثال توني لقطر
تخيل أنك لقطته في نفس الفترة أبل
الوليد بن طلال أحسه كان يملك 5% وباعها
لو يملكها...
لو معك 10 آلاف دولار في أبل قبل عشرين سنة
اليوم 8 مليون دولار
لا إله إلا الله
لو معك 10 آلاف دولار في أمازون
اليوم تقريبًا حدود المليونين أو...
10 ألف دولار طبعًا، بس ليش؟
بس طبعًا أيش احتمال أن الواحد جاء ولقطها...
شبه مستحيل
لكن استثمارك في صندوق مؤشرات يضمن لك أنك تملكها
كجزء من محفظتك ليه؟
لأن دائمًا صندوق مؤشرات ياخذ أفضل وأكبر الشركات
أبل دخلت المؤشر في عام 1982
دخلت فيه في عام 1982
أمازون دخلت المؤشر عام 2005
معظم النمو في أمازون جاء بعد 2005
معظم النمو في أبل جاء في التسعينيات
وتسلا الظاهر ما دخلت اللَّا قبل أربع سنين أو شيء زي كذا صح؟
صحيح
فالفكرة أنه...
فهذا ميزة أنك تستثمر في المؤشر أنك تضمن أنك تلحق في...
وغير كذا حتى في واحدة من الدراسات شافت أنك...
تخيل واحد، حتى لو نوَّع
طبعًا تحرص بدون شك على القوائم المالية
تشوف استثمارك على المدى البعيد، أنا ما أشوفه كسهم الرقم
أنا أشوفه كشركة أنا داخل معها شريك
غير كذا واحدة من الدراسات المثيرة للاهتمام
قارنت ما بين واحد جاء قبل عشرين سنة
بَنى محفظته في شركة توزع
وفي شركات ما توزع
اللي توزع طلعت تعطي عائد أكبر بكثير
جزء من السبب، وعلمًا أنها شركة عمومًا أفضل
لأن الأفضل عادة هو اللي يوزع
وفي جزء ثاني أنه العائد التراكمي
لأنه يوزع فهذا يسمح لك أن تعيد استثمار التوزيعات الأخرى
فهنا الأثر التراكمي يصير عالي
«ألبرت اينشتان» يقول: العائد التراكمي
والفائدة المركبة في فكرة أن الربح يجيب لك ربح
هذا يقول أنها يسميه معجزة الدنيا الثامنة
لأنه فعلاً أثره كبير مرة
تخيل مثالنا «خالد» قبل شوي أنه هو دفع 55 ألف
بس جاءه 4 مليون
تتكلم عن تقريبًا 86%
من المبلغ اللي جاءه ومن الأرباح، وأرباح الأرباح
الله يزيد أرباحكم وأرباحنا
وأرباحكم
الجميع يارب
اللهم آمين
الشكر لك
شكرًا لك، شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لعادل باعطيه في الإعداد
ووهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
وعبدالعزيز المزي في التسجيل
والهندسة الصوتية عند محمد الحسن
وفي التلوين: عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج: أيمن الحمادي
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، ألقاكم